This episode is brought to you by Lloyds, which has been backing British ambition for over 250 years. Now, when you think about it, every dynasty in history has boiled down to two important elements, aspiration and action. And a classic example of this from British history, the rise of the House of Wessex, the family of Alfred the Great and his heirs, who between them established the United Kingdom of England. Yeah, it's a great story, isn't it, Tom? Great lesson in leadership, I think, for anybody. So Alfred and his heirs, they marry idealism and pragmatism.
本期节目由劳埃德银行（Lloyds）赞助播出，该银行两百五十多年来一直致力于支持英国的雄心壮志。说起来，历史上任何一个王朝的兴衰归根结底都离不开两个重要因素：抱负与行动。英国历史上有一个经典的例子，那就是威塞克斯王朝的崛起，即阿尔弗雷德大帝及其继承人的家族，他们共同建立了英格兰联合王国。没错，这是一个伟大的故事，不是吗，汤姆？我认为这对任何人来说都是一堂很棒的领导力课程。所以，阿尔弗雷德和他的继承人们将理想主义与务实精神完美结合。
They're brilliant at alliances. They're brilliant at managing power. They're brilliant of course at managing their money, which is a key part of political leadership. And of course, we are all reaping the rewards of their wisdom and foresight. When it's time to make your next move, you can bank on Lloyd's to be ready when you are. Because from new businesses to new homes and new life chapters,
他们擅长结盟，擅长驾驭权力，当然也擅长理财，而理财正是政治领导力的关键部分。当然，我们都在享受他们智慧与远见带来的成果。当您需要做出下一个重大决策时，劳埃德银行随时准备为您提供支持。因为从新创企业到新居，再到人生的新篇章，
backed by generations of hope and ambition, you can see, Tom, why 14 million people trust Lloyds to help make their dreams a reality. Based on Lloyd's internal customer data from March 26. No one can really doubt that some kinds of why, are simply better than others. Nor does it come as news to anyone, that when wines are made from the same vat, one cask will often turn out to be superior to the other, either because of the material that the cask has been made from, or due to some other circumstance. Nevertheless,
在几代人希望与抱负的支撑下，汤姆，您就能明白为什么一千四百万客户信任劳埃德银行，并将其视为实现梦想的助力。数据基于劳埃德银行2026年3月的内部客户数据。没有人会怀疑，某些种类的葡萄酒确实优于其他种类。同样，当葡萄酒出自同一个大桶时，其中一个木桶里的酒往往会更胜一筹，这要么是因为木桶的材质，要么是因为其他环境因素，这也不是什么新闻。尽管如此，
even though there is a general consensus as to the best wines, one that's been arrived at after many years, there can be no accounting for personal taste. A famous story is told which illustrates this. One of the freedmen in the household of the deified Augustus, a man celebrated for his connoisseurship and his palate, accompanied Augustus on a visit to a house. Brought a local wine by the master of the house, he tasted it and then delivered this verdict. This is not a wine that I have ever tasted before. I do not rate it. It is effectively vinegar. Caesar, however, will love it, and doubtless will insist on drinking it all the time. So that was the very first wine snob in history.
尽管人们对最好的葡萄酒有着普遍的共识，这种共识也是经过多年才达成的，但个人口味却无法解释。有一个著名的故事就说明了这一点。在神化的奥古斯都家中，有一位以鉴赏力和品味著称的自由民，他曾陪同奥古斯都去拜访一户人家。主人端上一杯当地的葡萄酒，他尝了一口，然后给出了这样的评价：“这酒我以前从未喝过。我不给它好评。它实际上就是醋。不过，凯撒一定会喜欢它，而且毫无疑问会坚持一直喝它。”所以，这就是历史上第一位葡萄酒势利小人。
No lesser figure than Pliny the Elder. And that story features in his enormous encyclopedia, which he wrote in the first century AD, and it's part of a long section of the encyclopedia, which is all about wine. And anyone who knows the work of Alan Partridge, will know that Alan Partridge has a huge world book of wine. and it sounds remarkably similar to Pliny's thing about wine,
他就是老普林尼。那个故事被收录在他公元一世纪撰写的巨著《自然史》中，那是百科全书关于葡萄酒的长篇章节的一部分。任何了解艾伦·帕特里奇（Alan Partridge）作品的人都知道，艾伦·帕特里奇有一本巨大的《世界葡萄酒之书》，听起来和普林尼关于葡萄酒的论述惊人地相似，
because like Alan Partridge's World Book of Wine, Pliny the Elder catalogs it by region with great thoroughness and attention to detail. Pliny offers lists of all the great wines. He discusses viticulture, the different varieties of grapes, the influence of the soil, when you should drink a wine, when it should be young, old and so on and so forth, whether you should store it in clay or in wood or whatever.
因为就像艾伦·帕特里奇的《世界葡萄酒之书》一样，老普林尼以极大的严谨和对细节的关注，按地区对葡萄酒进行了分类。普林尼列出了所有伟大的葡萄酒。他讨论了葡萄栽培、不同品种的葡萄、土壤的影响、什么时候应该喝什么样的酒、酒应该是新的还是陈年的等等，以及你应该用陶罐还是木桶来储存它。
and Tom, you will no doubt bring a lot of expertise to this discussion of wine, like your hero Pliny the Elder, because I have seen you sampling wines in the Napa Valley, in Sonoma, twice in the Barrosa Valley, in Australia. And I will never forget the occasion in the, I think it was the Sonoma Valley, when the guy doing the wine tour put down two wines, he said, Now, one of these is a very heavy, rich red, and the other is a very light Pino Noir. Please identify which is which. And unerringly, you chose the wrong one.
汤姆，毫无疑问，你会在这次关于葡萄酒的讨论中展现出丰富的专业知识，就像你的偶像老普林尼一样，因为我见过你在纳帕谷、索诺玛，还有澳大利亚的巴罗萨谷两次品酒。我永远不会忘记那次，我想是在索诺玛谷，那个带我们参观酒庄的人放了两杯酒，他说：“现在，其中一杯是非常浓郁的红葡萄酒，另一杯是非常清淡的黑皮诺。请辨别哪杯是哪杯。”结果，你毫不犹豫地选错了。
And it was a tremendous moment. But you're going to bring the same level of forensic expertise to this episode. Well, when I suggested doing this subject, I knew that you would feel in safe hands because you have an enormous respect for my knowledge of wine. You know that I have an incredible ability to taste and all of that. What was it? The man of the bloke said that you got it wrong because you were and I quote, well, you were a supertaster? I was a supertaster.
那是一个非常精彩的时刻。但你会在这一集中展现出同样水平的法医般的专业知识。好吧，当我建议做这个主题时，我就知道你会觉得很有把握，因为你对我葡萄酒知识的尊重是巨大的。你知道我有令人难以置信的品鉴能力等等。那个人是怎么说的？他说你选错了是因为你，引用一下，你是一个“超级品鉴家”？我是个超级品鉴家。
So a supertaster is somebody who unerringly will get it wrong every time. Is that right? No, I'm so right that I'm wrong. And in being wrong, I'm right. I think that's how it works. Because your taste buds are so overdeveloped. Yeah. That you don't taste as ordinary mortals. Correct. So somebody could give you a glass of the cheapest rosé and you would identify it as the most expensive claret. And that's because you're too good at tasting. I probably would. And that's the level of expertise that I will be bringing to today's episode, which is all about the history of wine. And I love the fact that Pliny is the prototype for Alan Partridge and indeed for you, Dominic, and indeed for me.
所以超级品鉴家就是那种每次都会毫不犹豫地选错的人？是这样吗？不，我是因为太正确了，所以才错了。而在错误中，我是正确的。我想这就是它的运作方式。因为你的味蕾太发达了。没错。以至于你尝不出凡人的味道。正确。所以有人给你一杯最便宜的桃红葡萄酒，你也会把它认定为最昂贵的波尔多红酒。那是因为我太擅长品鉴了。我可能会那样做。这就是我将带入今天这一集的专业水平，这一集的主题是葡萄酒的历史。我喜欢普林尼是艾伦·帕特里奇的原型，当然也是你的原型，多米尼克，当然也是我的原型。
And for everyone who fancies themselves as a wine snob. I'm a little bit of a wine buff. A little bit of a wine buff. It's a reminder that wine has been a part of human culture for millennia. And the history of how people have grown it, have drunk it, have been unable to taste it correctly, have enjoyed it, and even on occasion have tried to ban it. I think it's a great theme for a history podcast. But there's another reason, too, why the history of wine, I think, is so interesting. And you mentioned all the various places on our world tours that we've been to, the kind of wine growing areas of the world.
以及所有自认为是葡萄酒势利小人的人。我算是一个葡萄酒爱好者。一个小小的葡萄酒爱好者。这提醒我们，葡萄酒几千年来一直是人类文化的一部分。人们种植它、饮用它、无法正确品尝它、享受它，甚至偶尔试图禁止它的历史。我认为这是一个很棒的历史播客主题。但葡萄酒的历史之所以如此有趣，还有另一个原因。你提到了我们在世界巡回演出中去过的所有各种地方，那些世界上的葡萄酒产区。
And one of those was the Barrossa Valley, which we visited last November when we were in Australia outside Adelaide. And there would obviously have been no wine grown there without the British Empire because the first fleet, when it arrived in Botany Bay in 1788 with all the convicts, it also brought wines, which were cuttings from Rio in Brazil and from the Cape. And so that's where the Australian wine industry began. But Barossa Valley is outside Adelaide in South Australia. In South Australia, there were no convicts, whoever wanted to go there. And loads of Germans went, didn't they? And they set up weird German bowling courts. It's like being back in the Barossa Valley with our wine guide, Kim, listening to you on this.
其中之一就是巴罗萨谷，我们去年十一月在澳大利亚阿德莱德郊外访问过那里。如果没有大英帝国，那里显然不会有葡萄酒种植，因为第一舰队在1788年抵达植物湾时，除了所有的囚犯，还带来了葡萄藤，这些葡萄藤是来自巴西里约和好望角的插条。这就是澳大利亚葡萄酒工业的开端。但巴罗萨谷在南澳大利亚的阿德莱德郊外。在南澳大利亚，没有囚犯，谁想去都可以。很多德国人去了，不是吗？他们建立了奇怪的德国保龄球场。这就像和我们的葡萄酒向导金一起回到巴罗萨谷，听你讲这些。
Yeah, I could listen to this all day. I've only heard it twice. So a third time. Brilliant. So the Barossa Valley was settled by Germans, and they brought their own tradition. of viticulture. And where did those traditions come from? Well, they had originally been introduced to Germany by the Romans back in the age of pliny. So everything, everything connects. Whoa, that's history. Like the curling of a vine tendril. Brilliant. And people may be wondering,
是的，我可以听这个听一整天。我只听过两次。所以这是第三次。太棒了。所以巴罗萨谷是由德国人定居的，他们带来了自己的葡萄栽培传统。这些传统是从哪里来的？嗯，它们最初是在普林尼时代由罗马人引入德国的。所以一切，一切都是相互关联的。哇，这就是历史。就像卷曲的葡萄藤卷须一样。太棒了。人们可能在想，
where did the Romans get their wine from? We will be finding out in today's episode. Because actually, the story of wine reaches back a very, very long way. Some might say, all the way back to the asteroid which wiped out the dinosaurs at the end of the cretaceous period and also incinerated many of the forests that covered the planet. And so you have these in the centuries that follow the asteroid hitting, you have these young forests that are regenerating. And this apparently is perfect for vines because they were able to kind of curl up these young trees and thrive in the post-asteroid Earth by filling gaps in the ecosystem. And I commend Jean-Baptiste Bosque, who is my daughter Katie's new French boyfriend for that information.
罗马人从哪里得到他们的葡萄酒？我们将在今天的节目中找到答案。因为实际上，葡萄酒的故事可以追溯到非常非常久远以前。有些人可能会说，一直追溯到白垩纪末期消灭恐龙并烧毁了覆盖地球的许多森林的小行星。所以，在小行星撞击后的几个世纪里，这些年轻的森林正在再生。这显然对葡萄藤来说是完美的，因为它们能够缠绕在这些幼树上，并通过填补生态系统中的空白在小行星撞击后的地球上茁壮成长。我向我女儿凯蒂的新法国男友让-巴蒂斯特·博斯克（Jean-Baptiste Bosque）推荐这个信息。
He's not only a wine expert, a sommelier, but he's also very knowledgeable about dinosaurs. And so I commend Katie's taste. But we're not the rest of the prehistory. Let's stick to the history. And of course, there is a lot of it because the history of wine spans at least 8,000 years. So there's a lot to cover. We can't cover it all. So I thought we could look at seven key moments in the history of wine moments that will enable us to trace its emergence, its spread, its evolution into what it is now, which is basically a kind of $500 billion industry.
他不仅是一位葡萄酒专家、侍酒师，而且对恐龙也非常了解。所以我称赞凯蒂的品味。但我们不是史前史的其余部分。让我们坚持历史。当然，历史有很多，因为葡萄酒的历史至少跨越了8000年。所以有很多要讲的。我们无法涵盖所有内容。所以我认为我们可以看看葡萄酒历史上的七个关键时刻，这些时刻将使我们能够追踪它的出现、传播、演变，直到它成为现在的样子，这基本上是一个价值5000亿美元的产业。
You know, there are, as you said, wineries in California and in Australia and New Zealand and South Africa and all across the world. So it's a huge story. where does it begin? Well, let's turn for that answer to the Bible and the book of Genesis. So we are told in the book of Genesis, Noah, as in the Ark, was the first tiller of the soil. He planted a vineyard and he drank of the wine and became drunk and lay uncovered in his tent. Let himself down. Let itself very badly down.
你知道，正如你所说，加利福尼亚、澳大利亚、新西兰、南非和世界各地都有酒庄。所以这是一个巨大的故事。它从哪里开始？好吧，让我们在圣经和创世记中寻找答案。我们在创世记中被告知，诺亚，就是方舟里的那个，是第一个耕种土地的人。他种了一个葡萄园，喝了酒，喝醉了，赤身露体地躺在帐篷里。让自己丢脸了。让自己非常丢脸。
So anyone who's got paralytic may have some sympathies there for Noah. And presumably he planted his vineyard on Mount Ararat, which is where the ark had come to rest. And Ararat is part of this kind of great range of mountains, south of the Black Sea, in the east of Turkey. So you've got the Taurus mountains, you've got the Caucasus, you've got the Zagros, the northern Zagros in Iran. And it's this kind of area where the key development in the history of wine took place. And Dominic, this kind of basically involves science. So it's the domestication of the Binaferra grape, which is basically the grape from which all the great types of grape have descended today. And because I'm not entirely confident of my ability to sum up the science precisely, I'm going to quote from an excellent forthcoming book by Kathleen Burke, the great historian of America.
所以任何喝得瘫痪的人可能都会对诺亚有一些同情。据推测，他把葡萄园种在亚拉腊山上，那是方舟停靠的地方。亚拉腊山是黑海以南、土耳其东部这一大片山脉的一部分。所以你有托罗斯山脉、高加索山脉、扎格罗斯山脉、伊朗北部的扎格罗斯山脉。这就是葡萄酒历史上关键发展发生的区域。多米尼克，这基本上涉及科学。所以这是酿酒葡萄（Vitis vinifera）的驯化，这基本上是今天所有伟大葡萄品种的祖先。因为我对自己准确总结科学的能力没有完全的信心，我将引用美国伟大的历史学家凯瑟琳·伯克（Kathleen Burke）即将出版的一本优秀著作。
Why in the global history, which is coming out, I think in September, and I saw a preview of it. And it's fantastic and go and pre-order it. And she writes, wild grapevines are male or female. I didn't know that. The female vines can produce fruit, but the male cannot, and so pollination has to take place by bees or the wind. What had to happen was cross-breeding either accidentally or by early man in order to create the hermaphroditic vine, able to produce fruit by itself.
《全球葡萄酒史》，我想九月份就要出版了，我看了预告。太棒了，去预订吧。她写道，野生葡萄藤有雄性和雌性。我不知道这一点。雌性葡萄藤可以结果，但雄性不能，所以授粉必须由蜜蜂或风来完成。必须发生的事情是杂交，无论是偶然的还是由早期人类进行的，以便创造出雌雄同体的葡萄藤，能够自己结果。
The vines are hermaphrodites. Did you know that? Everyone knows that, don't they? No, they don't. I've never heard that before. The people of the Republic of Georgia, not the Jimmy Carter, Georgia, but the Stalin, Georgia, they're very proud of this, aren't they? because they see themselves as the home of wine.
葡萄藤是雌雄同体的。你知道吗？每个人都知道，不是吗？不，他们不知道。我以前从来没听说过。格鲁吉亚共和国的人民，不是吉米·卡特的那个佐治亚州，而是斯大林的那个格鲁吉亚，他们对此非常自豪，不是吗？因为他们认为自己是葡萄酒的故乡。
They argue that Georgia is the place on earth where wine has been produced for longer than anywhere else. And I think most people would say they're right. Well, I don't think they argue it. I mean, I think they're right. Because there is firm archaeological evidence. And this was found very near Tbilisi, which is only about 100 old miles from Ararat. So maybe the Bible was right.
他们认为格鲁吉亚是地球上葡萄酒生产时间最长的地方。我认为大多数人会说他们是对的。嗯，我不认为他们是在争论。我的意思是，我认为他们是对的。因为有确凿的考古证据。这是在第比利斯附近发现的，距离亚拉腊山只有大约100英里。所以也许圣经是对的。
And they found shards of pottery, which has chemical traces of what seems to have been wine. And this dates all the way back to 6,000 BC. And then 2,000 years later, a village called Arani in Armenia has evidence of the oldest known winery. And so this is a large wine press that was found in a cave. And there were traces of withered grapevines and of skins and of seeds. And I gather that wine is made in Arani to this day. And I went and looked up to see what they have to offer. And apparently there's a Zulal-Arani dry red, which is described as balanced pure.
他们发现了陶器碎片，上面有似乎是葡萄酒的化学痕迹。这可以追溯到公元前6000年。2000年后，亚美尼亚一个叫阿雷尼（Areni）的村庄有已知最古老酒庄的证据。所以这是一个在洞穴中发现的大型压榨机。还有枯萎的葡萄藤、皮和种子的痕迹。我了解到阿雷尼至今仍在生产葡萄酒。我去查了一下他们有什么，显然有一种Zulal-Areni干红，被描述为平衡、纯净。
and lush. Lush. Wow. I know what people in the Holland House that will be drinking those Armenian Reds. I'm quite tempted to
和浓郁。浓郁。哇。我知道荷兰之家的人会喝那些亚美尼亚红酒。我很想
try that. Yeah, of course you are. I know your methods. I know you bought a massive bottle of wine in California, purely because it had Richard the 3rd's head on it
尝试一下。是的，你当然想。我知道你的方法。我知道你在加利福尼亚买了一大瓶葡萄酒，纯粹是因为上面有理查三世的头像
or something, isn't that right? There was some historical reason I bought it. And that was very nice as well. I think the thing that's interesting about the Iranian vine press isn't just that it's incredibly old,
或者类似的东西，不是吗？我买它是有某种历史原因的。那也非常好。我认为关于亚美尼亚葡萄压榨机有趣的事情不仅仅是它非常古老，
but also that is pretty big. And so that suggests that already in whatever it is, 4,000 BC, wine is being made on a scale large enough that it can be kind of handed out to other people. And so this is looking forward to the emergence of the wine trade because in due time wine starts to reach Iran, Mesopotamia, Canaan, so what's now kind of the Levant. Yeah.
而且它也相当大。所以这表明早在公元前4000年，葡萄酒的生产规模就已经大到可以分发给其他人了。所以这展望了葡萄酒贸易的出现，因为在适当的时候，葡萄酒开始到达伊朗、美索不达米亚、迦南，也就是现在的黎凡特地区。是的。
And the Canaanites are the forebears of the Phoenicians, and they rank as the first mass exporters of wine. And so they're number two on my list of the key moments in the history of wine. So the centre of the Canaanite wine trade, which begins in the sixth millennium BC, is the Becker Valley in Lebanon. Big wine place now. Chateau Musar, Massiah, very big, pungent, heavy reds,
迦南人是腓尼基人的祖先，他们被列为第一批葡萄酒的大规模出口商。所以他们在我的葡萄酒历史关键时刻名单上排名第二。因此，始于公元前六千年的迦南葡萄酒贸易中心是黎巴嫩的贝卡谷地。现在是一个很大的葡萄酒产地。Chateau Musar，Massiah，非常大、刺鼻、浓郁的红酒，
but very nice, I would say, weirdly produced in Hezbollah-controlled territory. Yeah. Because it's where Balbeck is, isn't it? the kind of the great Roman temple complex. Yeah. So it's still going strong. And Canaan becomes famous in the ancient world for its wines. So there's an Egyptian story that was written around 2000 BC,
但我会说非常好，奇怪的是在真主党控制的领土内生产。是的。因为那是巴勒贝克所在的地方，不是吗？那种伟大的罗马神庙建筑群。是的。所以它仍然很强劲。迦南在古代世界以其葡萄酒而闻名。所以有一个写于公元前2000年左右的埃及故事，
in which Canaan is described as a land where wine is more plentiful than water. And the reason that the Egyptians know to say this is because by 2000 BC, there is a lot of wine being exported to Egypt, also to Cyprus and to Crete, all of which become very keen on wine. And the reason that the Canaanites can transport it overseas is because they have invented the amphora. I'm sure most people would be able to picture what an amphora looks like, but just in case you can't, it has two handles. It's got a kind of pointed base so you can stick it in sand or mara or whatever. And it's got a very narrow neck, which you can then seal with a clay stopper.
其中迦南被描述为一个葡萄酒比水还充足的土地。埃及人之所以知道这一点，是因为到公元前2000年，有大量的葡萄酒出口到埃及，也出口到塞浦路斯和克里特岛，所有这些地方都变得非常热衷于葡萄酒。迦南人能够将其运往海外的原因是他们发明了双耳细颈瓶（amphora）。我相信大多数人都能想象出双耳细颈瓶的样子，但以防万一你不能，它有两个把手。它有一个尖底，所以你可以把它插在沙子里或泥里等等。它有一个非常窄的颈部，你可以用粘土塞子密封。
And having invented it, it's then used for thousands and thousands of years, actually right the way up to the coming of Islam in the 7th century AD. Have you ever had wine that was kept in an amphora? Because I have. There's a winery in the Alentejo in Portugal called Esperal. And there you go and do a tasting. And they have wine that's kept in steel that's being kept in oak barrels, obviously. So it tastes a little bit more oaky. And then they've got wine that's been kept in a clay amphora.
发明了它之后，它就被使用了几千年，实际上一直持续到公元7世纪伊斯兰教的到来。你喝过保存在双耳细颈瓶里的酒吗？因为我喝过。葡萄牙阿连特茹有一个叫Esperal的酒庄。你去那里品酒。他们有保存在钢罐里的酒，显然还有保存在橡木桶里的酒。所以它尝起来有点橡木味。然后他们有保存在粘土双耳细颈瓶里的酒。
Because that's what Pliny's talking about, isn't it? Is the difference between wood and clay? Of course. The different flavours that it gives you. And actually, it does taste different. It's got a very clayy and actually not unpleasant taste at all. And that's what most, I guess, most people in human history would have tasted when they drank wine, the taste of the clay amphra. Yeah.
因为这就是普林尼所说的，不是吗？木头和粘土的区别？当然。它给你的不同味道。实际上，它确实尝起来不同。它有一种非常粘土的味道，实际上一点也不难喝。我想这就是人类历史上大多数人在喝葡萄酒时尝到的味道，粘土双耳细颈瓶的味道。是的。
And it survives because it's incredibly useful. I mean, it's kind of an amazing piece of tech, really. And so it survives the collapse of the Canaanite civilization in the Bronze Age collapse in the early 1100s BC. Everything is kind of left in rubble in Canaan, but then you have like flowers emerging from the, from the first. frosts of winter, you have Phoenician civilization. And the Phoenicians are great merchants. They export even more wine over even greater distances than the Canaanites done. And in 1997, I read in Kathleen Burke's book, two Phoenicians ships were found off Gaza, about 50 miles off, by a US submarine. And this contained 781 and foray, which is equivalent to 20,000 wine
它之所以能存活下来，是因为它非常有用。我的意思是，这真是一件了不起的技术。所以它在公元前1100年代初的青铜时代崩溃中幸存下来，迦南文明崩溃了。迦南的一切都变成了废墟，但随后就像冬天的第一场霜冻中冒出的花朵一样，你有了腓尼基文明。腓尼基人是伟大的商人。他们出口的葡萄酒比迦南人更多，距离更远。1997年，我在凯瑟琳·伯克的书中读到，两艘腓尼基船只在加沙外海约50英里处被一艘美国潜艇发现。这包含了781个双耳细颈瓶，相当于20000瓶葡萄酒
bottles. So, I mean, that's a, that's a huge amount of trade. And other ships have been found that contained even kind of greater quantities. So the Phoenicians are able essentially to export wine across the entire Mediterranean and actually beyond. You mentioned Portugal. Just south of Portugal is Cadiz, ancient Gardez, is Phoenician settlement. And wine amphorae have been found there dating from around 800 BC. So they must be the oldest known amphorae in Iberia. I would guess. And of course, the Phoenicians are in direct competition with another ancient people who are very keen on wine. And these are the Greeks. And they are also heading west and they're also taking wine with them. And the classic account in literature of this is in the Odyssey, where Odysseus and his men are trying to get back to Ithaca from Troy. And they've picked up some 12 jars of a very precious red wine from a place in Thrace, the North Aegean, a place called Maron. And they end up with them on the island of the Cyclops. And they take these vases up as a kind of gift for the inhabitants of this island.
所以，我的意思是，这是一个巨大的贸易量。其他船只也被发现，其中包含更大数量的葡萄酒。所以腓尼基人基本上能够将葡萄酒出口到整个地中海，甚至更远。你提到了葡萄牙。就在葡萄牙南部是加的斯，古代的加德斯，是腓尼基人的定居点。在那里发现了可以追溯到公元前800年左右的葡萄酒双耳细颈瓶。所以我想它们一定是伊比利亚已知最古老的双耳细颈瓶。当然，腓尼基人与另一个非常热衷于葡萄酒的古代民族直接竞争。这就是希腊人。他们也在向西航行，他们也带着葡萄酒。文学中对此的经典描述是在《奥德赛》中，奥德修斯和他的手下试图从特洛伊回到伊萨卡。他们从色雷斯（北爱琴海）一个叫马隆的地方带走了12罐非常珍贵的红葡萄酒。他们最终带着它们来到了独眼巨人的岛上。他们把这些花瓶作为礼物送给这个岛上的居民。
The Greeks dilute the wine. So it's kind of 19 water to one bit of wine. But Polyphemus, the Cyclops, who turns out to be the host of Odysseus and his guys and ends up kind of trying to eat them all, he necks the whole lot. And he does that because he's a complete barbarian and he doesn't understand wine culture. And that is a reminder of the fact that the Greeks like the Phoenicians are not just exporting kind of physical quantities of alcohol. They are also exporting an entire culture, an entire way of life governed by rules, how much you dilute it. Right.
希腊人稀释葡萄酒。所以它是19份水兑1份酒。但波吕斐摩斯，那个独眼巨人，结果成了奥德修斯和他的手下的主人，最后试图吃掉他们所有人，他一口气喝光了所有的酒。他这样做是因为他是一个彻头彻尾的野蛮人，他不了解葡萄酒文化。这提醒我们，希腊人像腓尼基人一样，不仅在出口实体的酒精。他们还在出口一种完整的文化，一种受规则支配的生活方式，比如你稀释它的比例。对。
The kind of sociability that wine fuel, so the symposia in ancient Greek, you kind of lie around and drink wine and talk philosophy. And this is part of what is being exported. So the Phoenicians are exporting this. Spain, the Greeks are taking it to France. So they establish a colony, Massilia, which will become Marseille, around 600 BC. And of course, wine is going to have a very, very promising future in Gaul, aka France. So by the time the Roman Empire emerges, there is a wine culture that has spread from its homelands in the Near East across the Mediterranean and the Romans inherit this.
葡萄酒所激发的社交活动，所以古希腊的座谈会（symposia），你躺着喝酒，谈论哲学。这就是正在出口的一部分。所以腓尼基人正在出口这个。西班牙，希腊人正把它带到法国。所以他们在公元前6000年左右建立了马赛殖民地。当然，葡萄酒在高卢，也就是法国，将会有非常非常光明的前途。所以当罗马帝国出现时，一种从近东家园传播到地中海的葡萄酒文化已经存在，而罗马人继承了这一点。
And the Romans are the third way stop on our journey through the history of wine because the Roman Empire constitutes the first properly international wine culture. Because it's a giant marketplace. Globalized single market. Yes. Exactly. Yeah. Now, to begin with, I guess a bit like Americans in the.
罗马人是我们葡萄酒历史之旅的第三站，因为罗马帝国构成了第一个真正国际化的葡萄酒文化。因为它是一个巨大的市场。全球化的单一市场。是的。完全正确。是的。现在，起初，我想有点像19世纪或20世纪访问波尔多葡萄园的美国人。罗马人非常非常自觉地把自己看作是暴发户。他们担心自己是否在做正确的事情，有点像我去纳帕谷展示我的葡萄酒品鉴大师风范。他们默认最好的葡萄酒是希腊的，正因为如此，希腊葡萄酒变得最昂贵。是的。他们也是，听我们关于迦太基那一集的人，我们做过一集关于这座城市毁灭的节目，他们可能记得所有的迦太基图书馆都被处理掉了，但罗马人保留了一卷由一位名叫马戈（Mago）的农学家写的书。他们想保留他的原因之一是马戈是一位非常著名的关于如何种植葡萄酒的作家。所以那被翻译了
19th or 20th century visiting the vineyards of Bordeaux. The Romans are very, very conscious of themselves as kind of parvenus. They're anxious about whether they're doing the right thing, a bit like me going and displaying my mastery of wine tasting in the Napa Valley. They have a default assumption that the best wines are Greek, and because of that, Greek wines become the most expensive. Yeah. They are also, people who listen to our episode on Carthage, we did one on the destruction of the city and they may remember that all the Carthaginian libraries kind of get disposed of, but the Romans keep one volume by an agronomist called Mago. And one of the reasons they wanted to keep him is that Mago was very famous writer on how you grow wines. And so that was translated
从迦太基语翻译成拉丁语，并对意大利葡萄园的生长产生了非常重要的影响。但实际上，发生的事情是葡萄酒深深地扎根于罗马意大利的土壤中，以至于当军团开始向地中海以外扩张时，葡萄酒成为了罗马文明的标志。它成为了罗马人身份的关键主题之一。实际上，有点像美国西部扩张中的威士忌，葡萄酒在罗马的帝国扩张中发挥了作用，比如进入高卢。所以在公元前二世纪，占领了南部。马赛，是罗马帝国的一部分。罗马人有点向北看，想知道他们将如何安抚所有这些
from Carthaginian into Latin and became a very important influence on the growth of vineyards in Italy. But actually, what happens is that wine beds down so deeply into the soil of Roman Italy, that as the legions start expanding beyond the limits of the Mediterranean, wine becomes a marker of Roman civilization. It becomes one of the kind of the key light motifs of what it is to be Roman. And actually, a bit like whiskey in the expansion of the American West, wine plays a role in Rome's imperial expansion, say, into Gaul. So in the second century BC, has occupied the south. Massilia, Marseille, is a part of the Roman Empire. And the Romans are kind of looking northwards, wondering about how they're going to pacify all these
生活在那里的可怕部落。所以商人们开始沿着河流进入高卢腹地，他们带着葡萄酒。高卢人绝对喜欢它。他们最终完全上瘾了，就像波吕斐摩斯一样，他们是野蛮人，所以他们不稀释它。他们沉溺于醉酒狂欢，引用一位希腊历史学家的话，他们最终醉得要么睡着，要么发疯。本质上，罗马商人所做的是创造一个酗酒者的市场。通过这样做，因为高卢人已经变成了酗酒者，商人们就可以提高他们的价格。完美。
terrifying tribes that live there. And so merchants start traveling up the rivers into the interior of Gaul, and they take wine with them. And the Gauls absolutely love it. They end up completely addicted, like Polyphemus, they're barbarians and say they don't dilute it. They kind of wallow in drunken binges, to quote one. Greek historian, they end up so inebriated that they either fall asleep or go mad. And essentially, what the Roman merchants are doing is to create a market of alcoholics. And by doing that, because the Gauls have become alcoholics, the merchants can then inflate their prices. Perfect.
为了确保只有罗马人能提供葡萄酒，元老院通过了一项官方法令，禁止向高卢人出售葡萄藤。所以葡萄酒的制造权保留在罗马人手中。结果就是，到了朱利叶斯·凯撒准备征服高卢的时候，汇率，我的意思是，是疯狂的。一安福拉葡萄酒基本上等同于一个奴隶。你知道，一个奴隶很值钱。所以这反过来在高卢人之间引发了战斗，因为如果他们想得到葡萄酒，他们就需要俘虏奴隶。所以这使得高卢人团结起来对抗罗马人的推进变得不可能。而对于罗马人来说，这是一个良性循环
And to make sure that it's only the Romans who can provide the wine, the Senate passes an official decree banning the selling of vines to the Gauls. So the manufacturing of wine remains in Roman hands. And the result of that is that by the time of Julius Caesar, who's going to conquer Gaul, the exchange rate, I mean, is insane. It's one and four of wine basically equates to a slave. You know, and a slave is worth a lot. And so this in turn generates fighting among the Gauls because they need to capture slaves if they're going to get the wine. So it makes any notion of Gallic unity against the advance of the Romans impossible. while for the Romans it's a virtuous circle
因为你用葡萄酒换取这些奴隶，然后你可以把他们卖给葡萄栽培者，他们可以用奴隶生产更多的葡萄酒，这会让高卢人喝得更醉，这反过来又促进了更多的战争，导致更多的奴隶。而且，你知道，这很棒。所以基本上葡萄酒是朱利叶斯·凯撒能够征服高卢的原因，
because you buy the, you get these slaves in return for the wine, you can then sell it to viticulturalists who can then use the slaves to make more wine, which then gets the ghouls even more pissed, and that in turn fosters more wars, which results in more slaves. And, you know, it's brilliant. So basically wine is what enables Julius East to conquer Gull,
葡萄酒历史中意想不到的维度，也许吧。那是一个意想不到的维度。所以当普林尼写作时，我们说了什么，公元一世纪，是吗？是的，公元一世纪。罗马的葡萄酒世界涵盖了相当多我们现在与葡萄酒联系在一起的地区。所以你提到了你有希腊。我的意思是，希腊现在不是一个巨大的葡萄酒强国，尽管希腊有一些不错的葡萄酒。
unexpected dimension of the history of wine, perhaps. That is an unexpected dimension. So by the time Pliny is writing, what did we say, the first century AD, was it? Yeah, first century AD. The Roman kind of wine world encompasses quite a lot of the areas that we now associate with wine. So you mentioned you've got Greece. I mean, Greece is not a massive wine powerhouse now, though there are some nice wines from Greece.
黎巴嫩的贝卡谷地，黎巴嫩生产一些非常好的葡萄酒。葡萄酒已经传播到法国。所以它已经在勃艮第、卢瓦尔河、摩泽尔河和莱茵河等地了，例如。所以那些处于罗马世界边缘的地区。但最重要的是，意大利。当奥古斯都、提比略等人掌权时，意大利是葡萄酒的家园和中心，不是吗？它已经从希腊甚至格鲁吉亚手中接过了接力棒。是的。
The Becker Valley in Lebanon, there's some very nice wines made in Lebanon. Wine has spread into France. So it's already in Burgundy, the Loire, the Moselle and the Rhine, for example. So those areas that are kind of slightly on the periphery of the Roman world. But above all, Italy. By the time Augustus, Tiberius and co are in charge, Italy is the home and the heartland of wine, isn't it? It's taken over from Greece and indeed from Georgia. Yeah.
所以希腊酿酒师基本上是手工酿酒师。罗马人正在以工业规模进行生产。我的意思是，他们有所有这些奴隶，例如。但他们不仅仅是那种大规模生产。他们也有非常棒的葡萄酒，其中经典被称为法勒尼安（Fallonian）。所以普林尼喜欢法勒尼安。我的意思是，基本上，所有的罗马人都喜欢法勒尼安。那是最好的。
So Greek winemakers are basically kind of artisanal winemakers. The Romans are doing it on an industrial scale. I mean, they've got all these slaves, for instance. But they're not just kind of mass producing. They also have really superb wines of which the classic is called Fallonian. So Pliny loves forlornian. I mean, basically, all the Romans love Fallenian. That is the best.
正如它在希腊所做的那样，它已经成为罗马文化的一部分。所以它绝对渗透了所有伟大的罗马诗人的作品。罗马诗歌中最著名的短语之一，至今仍在使用，“Carpe diem”（及时行乐），来自诗人贺拉斯，我的意思是，那是对葡萄栽培的隐喻。它是，你知道，采摘这一天，就好像这一天是藤上的一串葡萄。所以，在我们今天仍在使用的日常语言中，有一种关于罗马人与葡萄酒的关系受到多深影响的痕迹元素。现在，当然，罗马权力的崩溃，当它在西方到来时
as it had done in Greece, it has become part of Roman culture. So it absolutely saturates the work of all the great Roman poets. And one of the most famous phrases from Roman poetry, still in use, Carpe diem, from the poet Horace, I mean, that's an illusion to viticulture. It's, you know, pluck the day as though the day is kind of a bunch of grapes on the vine. So there is, you know, in our kind of everyday language still used today, is a kind of trace element of how deeply the Romans were influenced by their relationship with wine. Now, of course, the collapse of Roman power when it comes in the West
结束了这种因饮用葡萄酒而结合在一起的共同文明感。在罗马陷落的混乱中，葡萄园要么被摧毁，要么被完全废弃。作为西方省份新主人的野蛮人，倾向于喝啤酒而不是葡萄酒。嗯，啤酒更容易生产，你不需要使用如此复杂的系统来生产啤酒。而且它更适合北方那种较冷的气候。但主要因素只是罗马单一市场的破坏。你知道，根本没有以前存在的贸易网络。然而，话虽如此，葡萄酒文化并没有
ends this sense of a common civilization that had been bonded by the drinking of wine. Amid the chaos of Rome's fall, vineyards are either destroyed or they're abandoned completely. The barbarians, who are the new masters of the Western provinces, tend to drink beer in preference to wine. wine. Well, beer is easier to produce, you don't use such a sophisticated system to produce beer. And it's better suited to the kind of colder climates of the north. But the main factor is just the destruction of the Roman single market. You know, they just aren't the kind of the trade networks that had previously existed. However, all that said, the wine culture is not
被抹去。它确实幸存了下来。有两件事真正使这成为可能。首先是存在某种贸易联系。它们确实幸存了下来。所以莱茵河尤其至关重要。它被称为葡萄酒之河。如此多的葡萄酒顺流而下。正是从这些葡萄酒中，它最终到达了斯堪的纳维亚，例如，在那里葡萄酒在维京精英中变得非常受欢迎，尽管事实上，或者实际上可能是因为事实上它太贵了。我的意思是，每个去过斯堪的纳维亚的人都知道，斯堪的纳维亚的葡萄酒贵得离谱。重点不是葡萄酒当时和现在一样，是精致的标志吗？它被视为，它与罗马文化等同，因此它很受推崇。
obliterated. It does survive. And there are two things really that make that possible. The first is that there are kind of trade links. They do survive. So the Rhine in particular is absolutely crucial. comes to be called a river of wine. So much wine flows down it. And it's from the wine that it ends up reaching Scandinavia, for instance, where wine becomes very popular with the Viking elites, despite the fact or actually maybe because of the fact that it is so expensive. I mean, everyone who's been to Scandinavia knows that wine in Scandinavia is madly expensive. Isn't the point that wine then, as now, is a marker of sophistication. It's seen as, It's identified with Roman culture and therefore it's prestigious.
是的。所以它在整个中世纪早期保持了这种声望。当然，另一个原因是基督教，因为葡萄酒对基督教仪式非常重要。如果你要庆祝圣餐，弥撒，你需要葡萄酒。所以中世纪早期的修道院特别热衷于葡萄园，同样，特别是在德国。所以沿着莱茵河的全长，你有这些带有葡萄园的修道院，这就是使莱茵河能够成为葡萄酒贸易的伟大渠道的原因。而贵族，出于你所说的原因，多米尼克，他们变得非常热衷于它。早在六世纪，
Yeah. And so it maintains this prestige throughout the kind of the early Middle Ages. The other reason, of course, is Christianity because wine is incredibly important to Christian ritual. If you're going to celebrate the Eucharist, the mass, you need wine. And so abbeys in particular in the early Middle Ages are great enthusiasts for vineyards, again, particularly in Germany. So all along the length of the Rhine, you have these abbeys with vineyards and that's what enables the Rhine. to become this kind of great channel for the wine trade. And the aristocracy, for the reasons that you've said, Dominic, they become great enthusiasts for it. And as early as the sixth century,
法兰克人的法律，带有某种“血金”（wergild）的概念，即如果你杀了某人，你必须支付一笔法律规定的固定金额。在葡萄园工作的人的“血金”被定为犁夫或牧牛人水平的两倍，这表明葡萄园在法兰克人眼中已经显得多么受推崇和重要。在整个中世纪早期，将成为法国的地方开始比意大利更快地从当时的混乱中恢复过来。法国取代了意大利成为葡萄酒贸易的中心。但你仍然，在整个中世纪早期到中世纪盛期，仍然没有真正意义上的葡萄酒文化是国际化的。
the law of the Franks, with its kind of notion of veergilds, the idea that if you kill someone, you have to kind of pay a set amount of money, which is determined legally. The Weirgild of someone who's working on a vineyard is set at twice the level of a ploughman or a cowherd, which suggests how prestigious and how important vineyards are already coming to seem to the Franks. And over the course of the early Middle Ages, what will become France starts to recover quicker from the chaos of the time than Italy. And France comes to replace Italy as the center of the wine trade. But you still, all the way through the early Middle Ages into the high middle ages, there's still no real sense of a wine culture that is intercourse.
在规模上，像罗马帝国时期那样。直到1596年，也就是文艺复兴时期，有一位意大利学者，一个叫安德烈亚·巴奇（Andrea Bacci）的人。他出版了一部伟大的七卷本葡萄酒调查。这是自1500年前普林尼以来写的第一部伟大的葡萄酒调查。当然，普林尼对它有巨大的影响。但当然，我们已经谈到了罗马的连续性，汤姆。所以罗马统治下生产葡萄酒或因葡萄酒而闻名的地区今天仍然受到推崇。但也有明显的例外。这部分是因为曾经的东罗马帝国的大部分地区已经被伊斯兰军队接管。显然，葡萄酒在伊斯兰文化中的地位与在基督教文化中非常不同。是的。嗯，我们已经提到双耳细颈瓶，自库尔纳克时期早期以来就一直存在，它们在7世纪消失了，这一时期见证了哈里发国在曾经的罗马和波斯帝国的大部分地区建立，这两个帝国都非常热衷于葡萄酒。
international in its scale of the kind that it existed under the Roman Empire. And it's as late as 1596. So, you know, well into the Renaissance, when you have an Italian scholar who's a guy called Andrea Bacci. And he published a great seven-volume survey of wine. And this is the first great survey of wine that has been written since Pliny, 1500 years before. And of course, Pliny is a massive influence on it. But of course, we've talked about the Roman continuity, though, Tom. So areas that produced wine under the Romans or were celebrated for their wine are still celebrated today. But there are obvious exceptions to that. And that's partly because much of what was once the Eastern Roman Empire has been taken over by the armies of Islam. And obviously wine has a very different place in Islamic culture than it does in Christian. Yeah. Well, we mentioned already how amphorae, which had been around since the early Kurnanak period, they vanish in the 7th century, which is the period that sees the caliphate established over much of what had been the Roman and Persian empires, both of which had been very keen on wine.
我认为哈里发国下对葡萄酒文化的排斥是一个非常戏剧性的标志，表明伊斯兰教渴望具有多大的变革性，并且显然会被那些处于哈里发国统治下的人所体验到。所以，在伊斯兰教中，关于葡萄酒的主流法律立场是明确的。你不应该喝它。所以根据古兰经，对于穆斯林来说，我的意思是，字面上它是语言形式的神性，葡萄酒是一种可憎之物。它是撒旦发明的，目的是鼓励人们打架斗殴，并分散信徒的注意力，引用古兰经的话，从纪念上帝和祈祷中分散注意力，你们难道不戒除吗？这种古兰经的判决得到了圣训的支持，圣训是关于
And I think the repudiation of the culture of wine under the caliphate is a very dramatic marker of just how transformative Islam inspired to be and would obviously have been one that was experienced as such by people who come under the caliphate. So in Islam, the mainstream legal position on wine is unambiguous. You shouldn't drink it. So according to the Quran, which for Muslims is, I mean, literally it's divinity in the form of language, wine is an abomination. And it's been invented by Satan to encourage people to kind of brawl and fight and to distract the faithful from, and I quote from the Quran, from the remembrance of God and from prayer, will ye not then? abstain. And this Quranic verdict is buttressed by the hadiths, which are the sayings above all of
穆罕默德先知的言论。所以先知被认为曾这样谈论葡萄酒。上帝诅咒葡萄酒，喝它的人，倒它的人，卖它的人，买它的人，挤压葡萄制作它的人，为他制作它的人，运输它的人，带给它的人。然后是你在哈里发国最初几个世纪出现的逊尼派伊斯兰教中的四个法律学派。所有这四个学派在对待饮酒的惩罚和制裁方面都非常严格。所以普遍的共识是，如果你喝酒并且你是一个自由人，你会受到80鞭刑
Muhammad, the prophet. So the prophet is supposed to have spoken as follows about wine. God has cursed wine, the one who drinks it, the one who pours it, the one who sells it, the one who buys it, the one who squeezes the grape to make it, the one for whom it is made, the one who transports it, the one to whom it is brought. And then there are the four legal schools that you get in Sunni Islam that emerge in the first centuries of the caliphate. And all four of these are very strict in their attitude to punishments for drinking wine, the sanctions. So the general consensus is that if you drink wine and you are a free person, you get 80 lashes
的鞭打。如果你是一个奴隶，你会受到40鞭刑。一些学派强调先知的一句圣训，说你应该用剥去叶子的棕榈枝鞭打。还有用拖鞋打屁股。古怪。我猜这可能比挨鞭子好。但我的意思是，听起来都不好玩。
of the whip. And if you are a slave, you get 40 lashes. Some schools emphasize a saying of the prophet a hadith, which say that you should be lashed with palm branches stripped of their leave. and also spanked with a slipper. Quaky. That's probably better than getting a whip, I would guess. But I mean, neither of them sound fun.
拖鞋是比利·班塔（Billy Banta）身上发生的事吗？这似乎是一种非常奇特的惩罚。宿舍宴会。是的，因为举行宴会和偷果酱之类的东西。不过，饮酒确实存在，不是吗？是的。部分原因是古兰经中有一些地方以更积极的方式描述了葡萄酒。
Slippers what happens to like Billy Banta? That seems like a very peculiar punishment. Dorm feasts. Yeah, for having feasts and stealing jam and stuff. Wine drinking does persist, though, no? Yeah. Partly because there are moments in the Quran where wine is described in a more positive way.
拖鞋？那比利·班塔（Billy Banta）发生了什么事？这似乎是一种非常奇特的惩罚。宿舍宴会。是的，因为举办宴会和偷果酱之类的东西。不过，饮酒的习惯还是保留了下来，不是吗？是的。部分原因是《古兰经》中有些地方对酒的描述比较正面。
So there are absolutely there are ambivalences in the Islamic attitude. to wine. So I've given the kind of the hardcore perspective. You are right. There are verses in the Quran that have a slightly less strict attitude to wine. So there's one that kind of seems to imply that wine might have positives as well as negatives. And there's also one that seems to imply that it's okay to get drunk as long as you're not going to then go and pray. The problem is that these verses, according to Islamic scholarly tradition, had preceded the verse. that explicitly bans alcohol and therefore, according to Islamic scholarship, are abrogated. However, if you want to drink and you go to heaven, there's great news because the Quran promises
所以伊斯兰教对葡萄酒的态度确实存在矛盾。我刚才讲的是那种强硬派的观点。你是对的，古兰经中确实有一些对葡萄酒态度稍微没那么严厉的经文。其中有一段似乎暗示葡萄酒既有积极的一面，也有消极的一面。还有一段似乎暗示，只要你不去祈祷，喝醉了也没关系。问题在于，根据伊斯兰学术传统，这些经文出现在明确禁止饮酒的经文之前，因此根据伊斯兰教义，它们已被废止。不过，如果你想喝酒又想上天堂，那有个好消息，因为古兰经承诺
that up in heaven there will be rivers of wine and they will be a joy to those who drink. Superb. And I think you're right that those verses do provide scope for those in the Islamic world who do want to have an occasional taste of wine. Yeah. Among whom rank a large number of the caliphs. I mean, a lot of caliphs are very keen on wine. And the scope also for lawyers to do what lawyers do,
在天堂里会有葡萄酒之河，它们将成为饮酒者的快乐源泉。太棒了。我认为你说得对，这些经文确实为伊斯兰世界中那些偶尔想尝尝葡萄酒的人留下了空间。是的。其中就包括许多哈里发。我的意思是，很多哈里发都非常喜欢葡萄酒。这也为律师们做他们擅长的事情留下了空间，
which is always to try and get round legal prescriptions. So one of the four legal schools in Sunni Islam, the Hanafi's, they point out that the Quran has banned wine that has been made from grapes, but not from dates. And so they suggest that maybe if you make wine from dates, that would be fine. And they also rule that it's not the actual drinking of wine that annoys God. It's the getting drunk. So basically, if you can drink wine but not get drunk, then you're okay.
那就是总是试图绕过法律规定。因此，逊尼派伊斯兰教的四个法学派别之一——哈乃斐派指出，古兰经禁止的是用葡萄酿造的酒，而不是用枣酿造的。所以他们建议，如果用枣酿酒，那可能没问题。他们还裁定，真正惹恼上帝的不是喝酒本身，而是喝醉。所以基本上，如果你能喝酒而不喝醉，那就没问题。
I'll quote from Saddakad Khadri in his wonderful book on Sharia law, Heaven on Earth. This, according to these jurists, meant that Muslims could legally drink as much wine as they liked. And I quote, until they became incapable of telling a slave girl from a beardless boy. So bad news for lightweights, but good news for the rest of us. Yeah, exactly. I mean, I suppose the question that's left open is how do you become so inured to wine that you can drink four bottles and still tell a slave girl from a beardless boy apart? If you know, you know. So we did an episode about the golden age of Baghdad, didn't we?
我引用萨达卡德·卡德里（Saddakad Khadri）在他那本关于伊斯兰教法的精彩著作《人间天堂》（Heaven on Earth）中的话。根据这些法学家的说法，这意味着穆斯林可以合法地喝他们想喝的任何量的酒。我引用原文：“直到他们无法分辨女奴和无须少年。”这对酒量小的人来说是个坏消息，但对我们其他人来说是个好消息。是的，确实。我的意思是，我想留下的问题是，你怎么能对葡萄酒变得如此习以为常，以至于喝了四瓶还能分清女奴和无须少年？懂的自然懂。所以我们做了一期关于巴格达黄金时代的节目，不是吗？
And Baghdad at its peak, it's kind of medieval peak, there are loads of taverns. serving wine. But interestingly, they're run not by Muslims, but by Christians. So the wine trade is monopolized by Christians, right? Yeah, because Christians need it for the mass. And so that's fine. And they're not, they're not kind of bound by Quranic prescriptions and legal prescriptions. And Harun al-Rashid, who is the caliph at the golden age of Baghdad, the caliph, lots of the stories in the Arabian Nights. He sponsored a famous poet called Abu Nawas. So he of the dangling locks of hair. And he was notoriously transgressive, very dissolute, very fond of wine.
巴格达在鼎盛时期，也就是中世纪的巅峰时期，有很多供应葡萄酒的小酒馆。但有趣的是，经营这些酒馆的不是穆斯林，而是基督徒。所以葡萄酒贸易被基督徒垄断了，对吧？是的，因为基督徒做弥撒需要它。所以这没问题。而且他们不受古兰经规定和法律规定的约束。哈伦·拉希德（Harun al-Rashid），也就是巴格达黄金时代的哈里发，《一千零一夜》中许多故事里的哈里发，他资助了一位著名的诗人，名叫阿布·努瓦斯（Abu Nawas）。就是那个留着垂肩长发的家伙。他以离经叛道、非常放荡、非常喜欢葡萄酒而闻名。
And he wrote a notorious piece of poetry about the rivers of wine that flow in heaven, according to the Quran. As for that which is forbidden, whatever could be dafter, a thing banned in this world yet abounds in the hereafter. Yeah. Amazing. He rhymes in English as well as Arabic. Who knew? Yes. In other words, Islam is a kind of an amazingly rich civilization in which there are enormous shades of opinion and behavior.
他写了一首关于古兰经中天堂里流淌的葡萄酒之河的著名诗篇。至于那些被禁止的东西，还有什么比这更愚蠢的呢？在世间被禁止的东西，在来世却应有尽有。是的。太神奇了。他不仅在阿拉伯语中押韵，在英语中也押韵。谁能想到呢？是的。换句话说，伊斯兰教是一种极其丰富的文明，其中存在着巨大的观点和行为差异。
Right. And by the 13th, by the 14th centuries, the tension in the attitudes to wine in the Islamic world have come to foster kind of very sophisticated cultures within the overall civilization of Islam. And there are two kind of representative figures of these cultures. So the first, this is the guy who's not in favour of wine is a bloke called Ibn Tamir. He is a hardline Sunni reformist. He's trying to reform the Islamic world in the wake of the catastrophe of the Mongol invasions. And so he says, get rid of all this, you know, legal quibbling and attempts to soft soap, the Quran and the Hadiths. We've got to go back to basics.
没错。到了13世纪、14世纪，伊斯兰世界对葡萄酒态度的紧张关系已经开始在伊斯兰文明的整体框架内培育出非常复杂的文化。这两种文化中有两个代表性人物。第一个，也就是不支持葡萄酒的那个人，叫伊本·泰米叶（Ibn Tamir）。他是一位强硬的逊尼派改革者。他在蒙古入侵的灾难之后试图改革伊斯兰世界。所以他说，摆脱所有这些法律上的诡辩，以及试图粉饰古兰经和圣训的行为。我们必须回归本源。
So he's absolutely dogmatically opposed to wine. He's also very opposed to a kind of hip, new intoxicant that's appeared on the scene called Hashish. And Ibn Tamir describes hashish as being to wine as feces are to urine. So there's a marketing slogan. And he says that anyone who disagrees with his judgment is an apostate and therefore subject to the penalties of apostasy, which would include death. And Ibn Tamir is basically, he's the godfather of Salafism, of kind of Islamism. very hard-core radical jihadi Islam. Against that, there's a much more kind of hippy, 1960s-friendly kind of of Islam called Sufism. And one of the great representative figures of
所以他绝对教条地反对葡萄酒。他还非常反对当时出现的一种时髦的新型致幻剂，叫大麻（Hashish）。伊本·泰米叶形容大麻之于葡萄酒，就像粪便之于尿液。这真是一个营销口号。他说，任何不同意他判断的人都是叛教者，因此要受到叛教的惩罚，包括死刑。伊本·泰米叶基本上是萨拉菲主义（Salafism）和伊斯兰主义的教父，也就是那种非常强硬的激进圣战伊斯兰教。与此相对，还有一种更嬉皮、更符合60年代风格的伊斯兰教，叫苏菲主义（Sufism）。苏菲主义的伟大代表人物之一是
Sufism is a Persian mystic and poet called Rumi, who was a massive bestseller throughout the 60s and 70s in America. And in Rumi's poetry, wine serves as a metaphor for the experience of divine love. And so Rumi... in kind of poetry that is designed to seem shocking to its readers, says that the image of the soul that has opened itself up to the love of God is that of the drunk, someone who staggers around. He's so kind of overcome by intoxicants. Right. This is not because Rumi is saying, it's brilliant, go and get drunk.
一位波斯神秘主义者和诗人，名叫鲁米（Rumi），他在整个60年代和70年代的美国都是超级畅销书作家。在鲁米的诗歌中，葡萄酒被用作体验神圣之爱的隐喻。所以鲁米……在那种旨在让读者感到震惊的诗歌中说，向神的爱敞开心扉的灵魂形象，就是一个醉汉，一个摇摇晃晃的人。他被致幻剂所征服。没错。这并不是因为鲁米在说，这太棒了，去喝醉吧。
He's not offering this metaphor literally. He doesn't seem to have drunk wine himself, but he's using it kind of to imply that wine is the best metaphor that believers have for how God should be experienced. And so he writes these famous lines, before garden, vine and grape were in the world. Our soul was drunk with immortal wine. So wine is almost kind of, you know, it's a platonic notion of wine, something that has always existed. And he frames the spiritual path of the believer as being a journey back to the tasting of that primordial wine. So you can see.
他并不是字面上提供这个隐喻。他本人似乎并不喝酒，但他用它来暗示，葡萄酒是信徒体验上帝的最佳隐喻。所以他写下了这些著名的诗句：“在花园、藤蔓和葡萄出现在世上之前，我们的灵魂就已经沉醉于不朽的葡萄酒中。”所以葡萄酒几乎是一种柏拉图式的概念，一种一直存在的东西。他将信徒的灵性道路描绘成一段回归品尝那种原始葡萄酒的旅程。所以你可以看出，
why it would appeal to hippies, I guess, in the 60s, and why it appealed to lots of Muslims and has appealed to lots of Muslims throughout the course of Islamic history. Now, Ibn Tamir obviously sees this as rubbish. He's very opposed to the Sufis. He thinks they're basically not Muslim at all. And Rumi, in turn, he sees the sobriety of the conventionally pious people like Ibn Tamaya as a form of spiritual death as not really being Islam at all. And I think that what this illustrates is that even when wine is banned,
为什么它在60年代会吸引嬉皮士，以及为什么它在整个伊斯兰历史中吸引了许多穆斯林。现在，伊本·泰米叶显然认为这是胡说八道。他非常反对苏菲派。他认为他们根本不是穆斯林。而鲁米反过来，他认为像伊本·泰米叶这样传统虔诚的人的清醒是一种精神死亡，根本不是真正的伊斯兰教。我认为这说明了，即使在葡萄酒被禁止的时候，
it can still have a kind of massive, massive cultural influence. And of course, when it's not banned, well, the sky is the limit. All right. So let's take a break and we'll come back after the break to delve deeper into the limitless bottle of wine history. RBC Training Ground has discovered potential in over 20,000 Canadian athletes and counting. Your story could be next. If you've got the drive, they'll help you find your path to the Olympics. Let's see what you've got. free at rbc trainingground.ca.
它仍然可以产生巨大的文化影响。当然，当它不被禁止时，那更是无所不能。好了，让我们休息一下，休息回来后我们将深入探讨葡萄酒历史上那瓶无限的酒。RBC训练营已经发现了超过20,000名加拿大运动员的潜力，而且还在增加。下一个故事可能就是你的。如果你有动力，他们会帮你找到通往奥运会的道路。让我们看看你有什么本事。免费访问 rbc trainingground.ca。
Welcome back to the rest is history and you have not yet drunk your fill because we have talked about four of the key moments in the history of wine from prehistory to the present and we have three to go. And one thing that we have been lacking is one of the world's great wine heavyweights and that is our own dear country of England. Some people listening to this may raise an eyebrow at that and say England, wine, they're quite wrong of course because if England doesn't necessarily. necessarily produce the greatest wine. Surely we rank among the world's great consumers.
欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History），你们还没有喝够，因为我们已经讨论了从史前到现代葡萄酒历史的四个关键时刻，我们还有三个要讲。我们缺少的一样东西是世界上伟大的葡萄酒重量级选手之一，那就是我们亲爱的英格兰。听到这里，有些人可能会挑起眉毛说，英格兰，葡萄酒？他们当然错了，因为如果英格兰不一定能生产出最好的葡萄酒，我们肯定也跻身于世界伟大的消费国之列。
And actually, now, an Englishman is, am I right in thinking it is the English that gave us bottles of wine, Tom? The first modern wine bottle, not the first wine bottle. So wine bottles are actually 2,000 years old. They seem to have originated in Syria, in the first century BC. They get picked up by the Romans. Roman glass blowers kind of refined them. But they're never use for transportation because the glass is too fragile, they would smash. They're purely decorative, kind of markers of status. And in 1867, one of these wine bottles was found in a tomb in spayer on the Rhine, tellingly again, you know, the river of wine. And it dated from the fourth century and it contained liquid wine. And it is the world's oldest unopened wine bottle, although the
事实上，现在，英国人是……我没想错吧，是英国人给了我们葡萄酒瓶，汤姆？第一个现代葡萄酒瓶，不是第一个葡萄酒瓶。所以葡萄酒瓶实际上有2000年的历史了。它们似乎起源于公元前一世纪的叙利亚。它们被罗马人采用。罗马玻璃吹制工对它们进行了改良。但它们从未用于运输，因为玻璃太脆弱，会碎。它们纯粹是装饰性的，是一种地位的象征。1867年，其中一个葡萄酒瓶在莱茵河畔施派尔（Speyer）的一座坟墓中被发现，同样耐人寻味的是，那是葡萄酒之河。它的历史可以追溯到四世纪，里面装有液态葡萄酒。它是世界上最古老的未开封葡萄酒瓶，尽管
wine within it is not the oldest wine to have been found because that was discovered two years ago in a tomb in Spain. It was in an urn. And that dates back to the first century AD. Okay. Some vintages there. God knows what it would taste like. But the problem with with wine bottles up to this point, well, certainly for centuries, is that the glass is too delicate, right? So there's a huge problem. You're basically they're going to break. And it is. English glassmakers who solve this difficult technical issue. Hooray for us. So this happens in the early 17th century.
里面的酒并不是发现的最古老的酒，因为那是两年前在西班牙的一座坟墓中发现的。它装在一个瓮里。那可以追溯到公元一世纪。好吧。有些年份了。天知道它尝起来会是什么味道。但到目前为止，葡萄酒瓶的问题，或者说几个世纪以来的问题，是玻璃太脆弱了，对吧？所以有一个巨大的问题。基本上它们会碎。正是英国的玻璃制造商解决了这个困难的技术问题。为我们欢呼吧。这发生在17世纪初。
So in the 1620s, English glassmakers start to develop furnaces that are defied by coal rather than wood. And then the following decade, they introduce wind tunnels, which apparently produce even higher furnace heat. And at the same time, the recipe for making glass was changed. And I'm going to quote Kathleen Burke here, because I'm going to quote Kathleen Burke here, because I don't entirely understand what it means, but technologically minded people would. So the recipe for making glass was changed by raising the ratio of sand to potash and lime.
所以到了1620年代，英国玻璃制造商开始开发由煤炭而非木材加热的熔炉。接下来的十年里，他们引入了风洞，据说产生了更高的熔炉热量。与此同时，制造玻璃的配方也改变了。我要引用凯瑟琳·伯克（Kathleen Burke）的话，因为我不太明白它的意思，但懂技术的人会明白。所以制造玻璃的配方通过提高沙子与钾碱和石灰的比例而改变了。
If you have more sand, you just got a better bottle, basically. Can't have too much potash. No. Too much potash is never, never good. Yeah, definitely. So who's behind this? History records the name of one inventor in particular. He gets named in a parliamentary inquiry that was held in 1662 to identify who had basically invented.
如果你有更多的沙子，基本上就能得到更好的瓶子。钾碱不能太多。不。钾碱太多从来都不是好事。是的，绝对。那么谁是幕后推手呢？历史记录了一位发明家的名字。他在1662年举行的一次议会调查中被点名，该调查旨在确定是谁基本上发明了
this new unbreakable form of grass. And they fingered this absolute top lad called Ken Elm Digby. Oh, yeah. And Digby is a tremendous character. So he was raised Catholic. He was actually the son of one of the conspirators in the gunpowder plot who'd been executed. He becomes a privateer. He goes around capturing Dutch merchantman, which Dominic, I'm sure you approve of.
这种新型的坚不可摧的玻璃。他们指认了这个绝对顶尖的家伙，叫肯内尔姆·迪格比（Kenelm Digby）。哦，是的。迪格比是一个了不起的人物。他是在天主教环境下长大的。他实际上是火药阴谋案中被处决的阴谋者之一的儿子。他成为了一名私掠船长。他到处捕获荷兰商船，多米尼克，我相信你对此表示赞同。
I do. Splendidly, he sells into the Mediterranean and he negotiates the release of 50 English. English slaves from the Barbary pirates of Algiers. So that reflects well on him. He's then briefly imprisoned for killing a French nobleman in a duel. He has an absolutely shambolet record in the Civil War. He's kind of always hairing around losing battles, left, right and centre. But he becomes a massive favourite of Henrietta Maria, the wife of Charles I, and accompanies her into exile after her husband is executed. And then Henrietta Maria's son, Charles II, is restored to the English throne after the death of Cromwell in 1660. And it's in the wake of the
我赞同。他出色地航行到地中海，并谈判释放了50名被阿尔及尔巴巴里海盗俘虏的英国奴隶。这对他来说反映良好。后来他因为在决斗中杀死了一名法国贵族而被短暂监禁。他在内战中的记录简直是一团糟。他总是到处乱跑，输掉战斗。但他成为了查理一世的妻子亨利埃塔·玛丽亚（Henrietta Maria）的宠臣，并在她丈夫被处决后陪同她流亡。然后亨利埃塔·玛丽亚的儿子查理二世在1660年克伦威尔死后恢复了英国王位。正是在
restoration, so two years after the restoration, that this parliamentary inquiry is held and Digby gets the credit for it. And I suspect that part of that is because he's the favourite of Henrietta Maria. Yes, this is slightly undeserved, isn't it? There aren't loads of people working on this? And he's basically just the figurehead. Yeah, but he's a fun figurehead. And so I think I think we should celebrate him. So these bottles that Digby and various other entrepreneurs who are less interesting have developed, they come to be called English bottles across Europe. And an English bottle has glass that is thicker, it's heavier, it's stronger, and also
复辟之后，也就是复辟两年后，举行了这次议会调查，迪格比获得了功劳。我怀疑部分原因是他是亨利埃塔·玛丽亚的宠臣。是的，这有点名不副实，不是吗？没有很多人在研究这个吗？他基本上只是个挂名人物。是的，但他是个有趣的挂名人物。所以我认为我们应该庆祝他。所以迪格比和其他不太有趣的创业者开发的这些瓶子，在欧洲被称为“英国瓶”。英国瓶的玻璃更厚、更重、更坚固，而且
crucially, it's cheap to manufacture. And the glass is very dark because of the coal fumes. And this comes to be seen by consumers as a kind of mark of quality. essentially that is why wine bottles tend to be dark to this day. It's a kind of legacy of its origins in the 17th century. That is so interesting. It never occurred to me before, but yeah, why are they murky? And that's the reason.
关键是，制造成本低廉。由于煤烟，玻璃颜色非常深。这被消费者视为一种质量标志。本质上，这就是为什么葡萄酒瓶至今往往是深色的原因。这是它在17世纪起源的一种遗产。这太有趣了。我以前从未想过，但确实，为什么它们是深色的？这就是原因。
Well, yeah, it's because of us. So hooray. And crucially, the glass is strong enough to contain sparkling wine, because that sparkling wine has got CO2 that is trying to get out. And if the glass isn't solid enough, then it will kind of, explode and send shards of glass flying through the air. And up until the invention of English glass, if you kept sparkling wine in a cellar, you'd have to wear a helmet because it might explode at any moment.
嗯，是的，是因为我们。所以欢呼吧。关键是，玻璃足够坚固，可以容纳起泡酒，因为起泡酒里有试图跑出来的二氧化碳。如果玻璃不够坚固，那么它就会爆炸，碎片会飞向空中。在英国玻璃发明之前，如果你把起泡酒放在地窖里，你得戴上头盔，因为它随时可能爆炸。
You know, you might end up with a shard of glass in your eye. So very dangerous. But now, hooray, English glass has appeared on the scene. Initially, they're pear-shaped, then onion-shaped, and then by the 1740s, they've come to take on the shape that everyone will be familiar with now. And because you can then lie them down in rows, this facilitates the emergence of wine cellars in the form that people will recognize today. And these wine bottles, they have, of course, very narrow tops, and so they can be stoppered. And what you use to stopper it increasingly is cork.
你知道，你的眼睛里可能会扎进玻璃碎片。所以非常危险。但现在，欢呼吧，英国玻璃出现了。最初它们是梨形的，然后是洋葱形的，到了1740年代，它们变成了现在大家熟悉的样子。因为你可以把它们横着排成行，这促进了现在人们所熟知的葡萄酒地窖的出现。这些葡萄酒瓶当然有非常窄的瓶口，所以可以塞住。你用来塞住它的东西越来越多地是软木塞。
And cork is produced in Portugal. And in England, access to cork is facilitated in 1703 by the signing of what is very much a friend. of the rest of history, and that's the Methuen Treaty. And Dominic, we've had the Methuen Treaty quite a lot on the rest of history, haven't we? We have. We did a whole episode about the Methuen Treaty, I think, when we did the 12 days of Christmas or something like that. I can't remember exactly what it was.
软木塞产自葡萄牙。在英格兰，1703年签署的一项条约促进了对软木塞的获取，这非常符合《历史的其余部分》的口味，那就是《梅休因条约》（Methuen Treaty）。多米尼克，我们在《历史的其余部分》中多次提到《梅休因条约》，不是吗？我们提过。我想我们在做“圣诞节的12天”之类的节目时，专门做了一期关于《梅休因条约》的节目。我不记得具体是什么了。
But just remind people who may not remember what the Methuen Treaty is. So England is at war with France. So access to French wine has been cut off. The Methuen Treaty is a treaty that allows wool to go to Portugal, England's oldest ally. And at the same time, England's oldest ally. import duties on Portuguese wine. So Portuguese wine comes the other way. This is the sort of genesis of the English fascination with port. Port wine, isn't it? Yeah. Exactly. So when you go
但提醒一下可能不记得《梅休因条约》是什么的人。当时英格兰正与法国交战。所以获取法国葡萄酒的渠道被切断了。《梅休因条约》是一项允许羊毛出口到英格兰最古老的盟友葡萄牙的条约。与此同时，英格兰最古老的盟友降低了对葡萄牙葡萄酒的进口关税。所以葡萄牙葡萄酒通过另一条路进来了。这就是英国人对波特酒（Port）着迷的起源，不是吗？波特酒。是的。正是如此。所以当你去
to Porto and you go the banks of the Rivaduro, you see all the great, you know, port wine lodges, tailors and sandermans. But also in the Alentasia, which is the kind of Portuguese rural heartland, there are these great forests. I was actually only there a couple of weeks ago. There are all these forests that produce cork. And Portugal, still to this day, is the world's great producer of corks. Yeah. And again, the cork is a little bit like the dark wine bottle, isn't it? There are lots of people, particularly in the New World, in Australia and in California,
波尔图，去杜罗河岸边，你会看到所有伟大的波特酒庄，泰勒（Taylors）和桑德曼（Sandemans）。而且在阿连特茹（Alentejo），也就是葡萄牙的农村腹地，有这些伟大的森林。我几周前刚去过那里。有所有这些生产软木塞的森林。葡萄牙至今仍是世界上伟大的软木塞生产国。是的。而且软木塞有点像深色葡萄酒瓶，不是吗？有很多人，特别是在新世界，在澳大利亚和加利福尼亚，
who say, why we're still using cork? You know, a screw top is just as good. But cork is seen as a marker of prestige and quality. And, you know, if you buy a very expensive bottle of wine, you don't expect it to have a screw cap, you expect it to have a Portuguese cork. I mean, of course, in the early 18th century, cork does present a problem, which is how do you get the cork out. Right. And so the English, as well as inventing the modern wine bottle, also invent the corkscrew. And so the first mention of a corkscrew, it's described as a silver worm,
他们说，为什么我们还在用软木塞？螺旋盖也一样好。但软木塞被视为一种声望和质量的标志。而且，你知道，如果你买一瓶非常昂贵的葡萄酒，你不会指望它是螺旋盖，你会指望它是葡萄牙软木塞。我的意思是，当然，在18世纪初，软木塞确实提出了一个问题，那就是你怎么把软木塞拔出来。没错。所以英国人不仅发明了现代葡萄酒瓶，还发明了开瓶器。所以第一次提到开瓶器，它被描述为“银色的蠕虫”，
comes in 1681. And then, brilliantly, in 1720, there's the first poem about a corkscrew. And I will quote from it. So Roger set his teeth to work this way and that the cork he plied, and wrenched in vain from side to side, so we can't open it. Then Backus, the God of Wine. appears to him in a dream and gives him a cork screw and then the poem continues he to the cork applied the point then bending earthward lobe twixt his knees the bottle firmly fixed and giving it a sudden jerk from its close prison wrenched the cork to be fair everyone's anyone who's you know drinks wine has had a moment like that with a cork where basically something's gone hideously wrong and you can't get it out and you're just shaming yourself in front of your guests
出现在1681年。然后，精彩的是，1720年出现了第一首关于开瓶器的诗。我引用一下。所以罗杰咬紧牙关，用这种方式，那个方式，他摆弄着软木塞，徒劳地从一边扭到另一边，所以我们打不开它。然后巴克斯（Backus），葡萄酒之神，出现在他的梦中，给了他一个开瓶器，然后诗继续写道：他把开瓶器的尖端对准软木塞，然后弯下腰，双膝夹紧瓶子，猛地一拉，把软木塞从它紧闭的监狱中拔了出来。说实话，任何喝葡萄酒的人都有过那样的时刻，软木塞基本上出了大问题，你拔不出来，你在客人面前丢尽了脸。
But the corkscrew, so at this point the corkscrew is not a patented thing. It's not the first patent for it is not granted until the end of the 18th century, right? To a clergyman. 1795, and the clergyman is called Samuel Henschel. And I know about this because I went down a corkscrew-shaped rabbit hole. Because it turns out there are antique corkscrew obsessives online. Of course there are. Most of them seem to live in Canada for some reason.
但是开瓶器，在这一点上，开瓶器不是专利产品。直到18世纪末才获得第一个专利，对吧？给了一位牧师。1795年，这位牧师叫塞缪尔·亨舍尔（Samuel Henschel）。我知道这一点是因为我钻进了一个开瓶器形状的兔子洞。因为事实证明，网上有古董开瓶器狂热者。当然有。出于某种原因，他们中的大多数人似乎住在加拿大。
And they all came over and set up a plaque to, Samuel Henschel in Bochurch in the East End because that's where he'd been. And there are very detailed descriptions as to exactly what is revolutionary about this corkscrew that I've read about 10 times and I still don't really understand. But well done Samuel Henshiel. He invents the corkscrew. But I'm afraid Dominic that that's probably all we've got time for when it comes to English inventiveness on this particular episode because that was number five in our top seven moments in the history of wine. And now we need to come on to number six, which is the invention of the language of wine. And the language of wine, of course, is French.
他们都跑过来，在东区的博教堂（Bochurch）为塞缪尔·亨舍尔立了一块牌匾，因为那是他曾经待过的地方。关于这个开瓶器的革命性之处，有非常详细的描述，我读了大约10遍，还是不太明白。但干得好，塞缪尔·亨舍尔。他发明了开瓶器。但我恐怕，多米尼克，这就是我们在本期节目中关于英国创造力所能谈论的全部内容了，因为那是我们葡萄酒历史七大时刻中的第五个。现在我们需要进入第六个，也就是葡萄酒语言的发明。而葡萄酒的语言，当然是法语。
So now we come to our beloved neighbour across the channel. So the French have been producing wine all through this period. Well, since the Romans. Yeah, we talked about the Gallic enthusiasm for wine. They've been producing it through the Roman period. Bordeaux, when the English control Bordeaux in the Middle Ages. Yeah. That is producing claret for English tables.
现在我们来到我们海峡对岸敬爱的邻居。所以法国人在整个这段时期一直在生产葡萄酒。嗯，自从罗马人以来。是的，我们谈到了高卢人对葡萄酒的热情。他们在罗马时期一直在生产。波尔多，当英国人在中世纪控制波尔多时。是的。那是为英国餐桌生产红葡萄酒（Claret）。
And you were sneering at my inability to tell between a light and a heavy red wine. I wasn't sneering. I was just remarking. So claret comes for claret. It means lighter and that become anglicized claret. And it's a reflection of the way in which claret in the Middle Ages was a light red and now tends to be associated with kind of much heavier, kind of richer red wines. But of course, the English lose control of Bordeaux at the end of the hundred.
你当时在嘲笑我无法区分清淡和浓郁的红葡萄酒。我没有嘲笑。我只是在评论。所以Claret来自Claret。它意味着更清淡，后来变成了英语化的Claret。这反映了中世纪Claret是一种清淡的红酒，而现在往往与更浓郁、更丰富的红葡萄酒联系在一起。但当然，英国人在百年战争结束时失去了对波尔多的控制，
year's war and going into the 16th and then into the 17th century and it may be because that umbilical cord with england has been has been broken france's kind of role in the wine trade it ceases to be as absolutely central as it had been in the middle ages so it's not just the hundred years war that's having an impact there's also the rise of the dutch as the great global commercial power they do invest very heavily in french wine but they are also out-recognitioned neutering Portugal, reconnoiting Spain. They make a trade agreement with the Ottomans to buy Greek wines. And then, of course, the Methuen Treaty coming in between England and Portugal
进入16世纪，然后进入17世纪，这可能是因为与英格兰的脐带被切断了，法国在葡萄酒贸易中的角色不再像中世纪那样绝对核心。所以不仅仅是百年战争产生了影响，还有荷兰作为全球商业大国的崛起。他们确实在法国葡萄酒上投入了巨资，但他们也重新认识了葡萄牙，重新认识了西班牙。他们与奥斯曼帝国达成了一项贸易协议，购买希腊葡萄酒。然后，当然，《梅休因条约》在英格兰和葡萄牙之间生效，
means that port wine is much cheaper in England than French wine. And of course, it doesn't happen that France and Britain are just constantly at war throughout the late 17th into the 18th centuries. So I think all of that impairs the notion of France as being economically central to the wine. trade in the kind of the early modern period. But even as it's going into retreat perhaps economically, its cultural centrality is going on by leaps and bounds. And the legacy of that cultural centrality is with us today and it spreads around the world. So it's why there are winemakers in New Zealand who will talk about their terroir. It's why you have wines in
意味着波特酒在英格兰比法国葡萄酒便宜得多。当然，法国和英国在17世纪末到18世纪并不是一直处于战争状态。所以我认为所有这些都削弱了法国作为早期现代葡萄酒贸易经济中心的概念。但即使它在经济上可能处于退缩状态，它的文化中心地位却在突飞猛进。这种文化中心地位的遗产今天仍然伴随着我们，并传播到世界各地。这就是为什么新西兰有酿酒师会谈论他们的风土（terroir）。这就是为什么你在南非有会被贴上“特级园”（Grand Cru）标签的葡萄酒。这就是为什么在加利福尼亚，一个以没有城堡而闻名的土地上，会有酒庄（chateau）。是的。我发现这个过程最迷人的地方在于，它有点像西装的出现。我们做过一期关于那个的节目。你可以指出那个时刻，
South Africa that will be labelled Grand Cru. And it's why in California, a land famously without castles, there are chateau. Yeah. And the thing I find so fascinating about this process is it's a little bit like the emergence of the suit. And we did an episode on that. And you can kind of pinpoint the moment
当西装被发明时，多亏了塞缪尔·佩皮斯（Samuel Pepys）的日记，他是在复辟后的伦敦写作，也就是1660年代。塞缪尔·佩皮斯再次出现，提到了这个法语成为葡萄酒语言的过程。这是1663年4月10日的日记条目。多米尼克，你是一个非常
when the suit is invented, thanks to the diaries of Samuel Pepys, who was writing in post-restoration London, so in the 1660s. And Samuel Peepes pops up again with reference to this process whereby French comes to be the land. language of wine. And it's a diary entry for the 10th of April 1663. And Dominant, you're a very
佩皮斯式的人物。我的意思是，不是在每一个意义上。不。但在愉快的意义上。那种社交性。佩皮斯有阴暗的一面，我不赞同。无论如何，与杰·卡特勒爵士（Sir Jay Cutler）和格兰特先生（Mr. Grant）在伦巴第街的皇家橡树酒馆交流，诗人布鲁姆（Broom）是一个风趣幽默的人，我相信，如果他不是有点自负的话，在这里喝了一种叫“Ho-Bryan”的法国葡萄酒，有一种美妙而独特的味道，我从未遇到过。现在这太有趣了，不是吗，因为他叫它什么，Ho-Bryon？是的，他发音外语的方法非常像我。所以实际上是奥比昂（O'Brien），这是第一个，这太有趣了，第一个波尔多
peepsian figure. I mean, not in every sense. No. But the pleasant senses. The conviviality. There's a dark side's peeps that I don't, that I don't endorse. Anyway, off the exchange with Sir Jay Cutler and Mr. Grant to the Royal Oak Tavern in Lombard Street, where Broom the poet was a merry and witty man, I believe, if he'd be not. a little conceited, and here drank a sort of French wine called Ho-Bryan that hath a good and most particular taste that I never met with. Now this is so interesting, isn't it, because what's he call it, Ho-Bryon? Yeah, his approach to pronouncing foreign languages is very much mine. So it's actually O'Brien, which was the first, this is so interesting, the first Bordeaux
葡萄酒，也就是第一个在伦敦销售的红葡萄酒，不是……被贴上波尔多或Claret的标签，也不是因为他们过去总是贴标签，嗯，通常标签上会有葡萄酒商的名字，不是吗？是的。但佩皮斯喝的这瓶酒上有酿造这种酒的酒庄的名字。所以，奥比昂，它是第一个。它是由波尔多的安诺·德·蓬塔克（Anno de Pontac）生产的。他是那里省议会的主席。
wine, so the first claret to be sold in London, not... labeled as Bordeaux or as claret and not labeled because they always used to have the label, well, often the label they would have the name of the wine merchant, wouldn't they? Yeah. But this bottle that Peep's has been drinking has the name of the estate that made the wine. So, O'Brien, it's the first. And it's been produced by this guy called Anno de Pontac back in Bordeaux. He's the president of the provincial parliament there.
他对葡萄酒不是特别感兴趣，但他拥有完全的营销天赋。1666年，他利用伦敦对奥比昂的热情，这种对自己酒庄的营销，他派他的儿子去开设了实际上成为伦敦第一家餐厅的地方，那是一家非常豪华的酒馆，以安诺·德·蓬塔克本人命名，谦虚地称为“蓬塔克之首”（Pontack's Head）。它变得非常非常时尚。这意味着蓬塔克家族可以大幅提高他们对葡萄酒的收费。所以复辟时期伦敦葡萄酒的正常价格大约是两先令。但在蓬塔克之首的奥比昂可以卖到七先令。哇。蓬塔克证明的是，最终葡萄酒的
he's not particularly interested in wine but what he has a complete genius for is marketing um and in 1666 he's capitalizing on this kind of enthusiasm in london for ho brian you know this kind of marketing of his own estate um and he sends his son to open what effectively becomes london's first restaurant and it's a very luxurious tavern that um is modestly called pontack's head after owner de pontac himself. And it becomes a hugely, hugely fashionable. And that means that the Pontax can massively raise the price that they can charge for the wine. So the normal price for wine in Restoration London is about two shillings. But the Obrillon at Pontack's head can be sold for seven shillings. Wow. And what Pontack is demonstrating is that ultimately a wine is
价值在于人们愿意为它支付多少钱。当然。这最终是衡量葡萄酒的唯一客观方法。他意识到他真的发现了一些东西。所以他想卖第二种酒。他该怎么做呢？他开始将奥比昂作为他的“一级园”（first growth）进行营销，法语是“Grand Cru”。然后他将他第二个酒庄的东西作为他的“二级园”（second crew）进行营销，
worth what people are prepared to pay for it. Of course. That ultimately is the only objective way of measuring a wine. And he realizes he's really onto something. So he wants to sell a second wine. So how is he going to do that? He starts to market Ote-Briand as his first growth, which in French is Grand Cru. And then he markets that stuff from his second estate as being his second crew.
也就是他的二级增长。这再次建立了一个分类葡萄酒的模板，它将有非常非常长的存在时间。它被波尔多地区的其他酒庄所采用。所以到了1720年代，有三个其他酒庄像奥比昂一样进行自我营销。这就是拉菲（Lafitte）、拉图（Latour）和玛歌（Margot），如果你对葡萄酒感兴趣的话，这些是非常著名的名字。所以这些酒庄位于梅多克（Medoc），在吉伦特河（Girond）的左侧，也就是通往波尔多的河口。奥比昂本身，我的意思是，今天它基本上是波尔多的郊区。但它们都大致在同一个区域。
so his second growth. And this again is establishing a template for classifying wine that will have a very, very long existence. And it's one that gets taken up by other estates in the Bordeaux region. So by the 1720s, there are three other estates that are marketing themselves as O'DBriand had been marketing itself. This is Lafitte, Latour, and Margot, very famous names, if you were interested in wine. So these estates are in the Medoc, which is on the left side of the Girond, which is the estuary, which leads to Bordeaux. Odebriot itself is, I mean, today it's basically a suburb of Bordeaux. But they're all kind of roughly in the same area.
它们确立了自己作为波尔多葡萄园绝对贵族的地位。革命来了又走，该地区发生了可怕的屠杀，但葡萄园幸存了下来。到了1855年，拿破仑三世，当时是法国皇帝，他正在巴黎举办
And they establish themselves as the absolute aristocracy of Bordeaux vineyards. And the revolution comes and goes, terrible slaughter in the region, but the vineyards survive. and by 1855 Napoleon III, who is emperor in France by then, he's staging
一场伟大的万国博览会，他想利用它来展示法国最好的
a great universal exposition in Paris and he wants to use it to showcase the very best
葡萄酒。所以他要求葡萄酒经纪人列出一份最好的
wines that France has. And so he asks the wine brokers to come up with a list of the best
葡萄酒名单。他们开始工作，列出了60种最好的红葡萄酒，
wines. They get down to it and they draw up a list of the 60 best reds
每一种都被归类为“特级园”（Grand Cru），并被分为五个独立的等级。顶级等级只有四种葡萄酒。这些就是最初的
and each one is classified as a Grand Cru and they're placed in one of five separate classes. And the top class, there are only four wines. And these are the original
葡萄园。所以那是奥比昂、拉菲、拉图和玛歌。这是他们从未失去的地位。在那之后的所有时间里，只有一个葡萄园被加入其中。那就是1973年的木桐酒庄（Chateau-Mouton-Rostchild），它从“二级园”（Premier Crew）提升为“一级特级园”（Premier Grand Cru）。所以这是一个巨大的荣誉。这是全世界葡萄酒爱好者都能理解的语言。我认为这是法国持久文化声望的一个不可思议的体现。我的意思是，不仅仅是在葡萄酒领域，更广泛地说，它是奢侈品的一种象征。但多米尼克，为了我们敬爱的国家辩护，我认为这也象征着英格兰的文化声望，
vineyards. So that's Ode Brignon, Lafitte, Latour, and Margot. And it's a status that they have never lost. And only one other vineyard has been added to it in all that time. And that was Chateau-Mouton-Rostchild in 1973, which was promoted from Premier Crew to Premier Grand Cru. So a tremendous honour. And this is language that is understood by wine enthusiasts around the world. And it's an incredible manifestation of France's enduring cultural prestige, I think. I mean, not just in the field of wine, but more generally, it's a kind of emblem of luxury. But Dominic, sticking up for our in beloved country, I think it's also emblematic of England's cultural prestige.
因为1855年制定排名时，并不是基于客观的质量标准。它们是基于英国人愿意为葡萄酒支付多少钱。所以引用凯瑟琳·伯克的话，英国人长期以来因拥有被认为是世界上最好的味蕾而受到钦佩。因此，英国人愿意为这些葡萄酒支付的价格，为法国人提供了判断什么是最好的葡萄酒的标准。这不有趣吗？所以法国人酿造最好的葡萄酒，但决定哪些是最好的葡萄酒的人是英国消费者。我认为今天仍然如此。我的意思是，当你说是英国消费者时，显然是贵族消费者。嗯，你知道吗？很有趣。我们在谈论英国人的味蕾，但直到1950年代，大多数英国人一年中从来
because the rankings when they were drawn up in 1855 weren't based on kind of objective standards of quality. They were based on how much people in England were prepared to pay for the wine. So to quote Kathleen Burke, the English had long been admired for having what were considered to be the best pallets in the world. And so therefore what the English were prepared to pay for these wines provided the French with their standard for judging what the best wine. were. It's not interesting. So the French make the best wines, but the people who decide which those wines are are English consumers. And I think that's still true today. I mean, when you say English consumers, it's obviously aristocratic consumers. Well, do you know what? It's funny. We're talking about the English palate, but as late as the 1950s, most English people never,
不喝葡萄酒。这是一种精英排他的东西。是的。所以这非常像是上层阶级的东西。但是，嗯，你知道，这对波尔多很有效，但其他地区呢？现在，法国人在营销葡萄酒方面和酿造葡萄酒方面一样出色。所以1677年，哲学家约翰·洛克（John Locke）进行了第一次有记录的波尔多葡萄酒之旅之一。所以他是我们纳帕谷等地之旅的祖先。当然，他去参观了他所描述的蓬塔克在奥比昂的葡萄园。他去那里，期待着肥沃的土壤能生产出如此精致的葡萄酒，他真的很困惑。土壤太糟糕了。他写道，它只不过是纯白色的沙子
ever drank wine in any given year. It's such an elite exclusive thing. Yeah. So it's it's it's it's very much the kind of the upper classes. But, um, you know, this, this works well for Bordeaux, but what about other regions? Now, the French are as good at marketing wine as they are at making it. So in 1677, the philosopher John Locke, he, he goes on one of the first recorded wine tours of Bordeaux. So he's the, the ancestor of our tours around Napa Valley and so on. And of course he goes to visit what he describes as Pontax Vineyard at Hote Bryan. And he goes there and he's expecting kind of rich fertile soil to produce such kind of an exquisite wine and he's really puzzled. The soil is terrible. He writes, it's nothing but pure white sand
混合着一点砾石。人们会认为它几乎不适合种植任何东西。然后他向南走，游览了朗格多克（Longadoc）。同样，他注意到一个斜坡看起来越贫瘠、越砾石，上面生产的葡萄酒往往就越好。朗格多克的葡萄酒种植者告诉他，最终没有什么比他们种植的土壤质量更重要了，我引用原文：“这在很大程度上取决于葡萄酒的好坏。”当然，这是一个可以追溯到普林尼（Pliny）的概念。他对此非常着迷，土壤的质量。但在法国，特别是在19世纪，尤其是20世纪，这种关于土壤及其与所生产葡萄酒的关系的概念，开始具有一种近乎精神的品质。
mixed with a little gravel. One would imagine it's scarce fit to bear anything. And then he goes south, he tours the longer dock. And again, he notes that the more kind of barrenuous, and gravelly a slope looks, the better the wine tends to be that's produced on that slope. And he's told by the wine growers in the Longadoc that ultimately nothing matters more than the quality, and I quote, of the soil they plant in, on which very much depends the goodness of the wine. And this, of course, is a concept that goes back to Pliny. He's obsessed by this, the quality of the soil. But in France, particularly in the 19th and especially in the 20th century, This notion of the soil and its relationship to the wine it produces comes to have an almost spiritual quality.
它开始集中在一个本质上无法翻译的词上。这就是“风土”（terroir）。所以有过尝试。地质学家詹姆斯·威尔逊（James Wilson）将风土描述为葡萄园栖息地所有元素的总和。但我认为对法国人来说，它无法翻译很重要。因为法国在19世纪工业化程度越高，风土就越能为保守派所代表。我认为大多数拥有葡萄园的人往往是保守的。
And it comes to be focused in a word that is essentially untranslatable. And this is terroir. So there have been attempts. So the geologist James Wilson, he describes terroir as being the totality of the elements of the vineyard habitat. But I think for the French, it's important that it's untranslatable. because the more that France industrialises through the 19th century, so the more terroix comes to signify for conservatives. And I think most people who own vineyards tend to be conservative.
它开始代表他们担心受到攻击的东西。那就是“祖国”（La Patrie）的根源，古老的法国。法国人对他们古老土壤的依恋，感受到来自工业化、来自外国人、来自德国人、来自任何人的威胁。是的。对他们来说，风土是只有法国人才能真正理解的东西，这很重要。嗯，当然，这在20世纪后期当他们面临来自新世界的竞争时变得非常有用，
It comes to signify something that they are afraid is under attack. And that is the roots of La Patrie of ancient France. The attachment of the French to their ancient source. oil, the sense of being under threat from industrialisation, from foreigners, from Germans, from whoever. Yeah. It matters to them that terror is something that only the French can properly understand. Well, of course, becomes very useful later in the 20th century when they're facing competition
他们可以说，好吧，看，你可能有这个，你可能有那个，但你没有我们的传统和我们的风土。没错。没错。因为仅仅因为某种东西在精神层面上被深刻感受，并不意味着你不能用它来推销葡萄酒，这正是法国人正在做的，特别是在他们没有独家酒庄的地方，比如在波尔多。所以勃艮第（Burgundy）就是一个完美的例子。同样，法国一个非常非常著名的地区，但因为它没有通过海路与英格兰相连，它没有这种历史，这种血统。所以他们在勃艮第，将他们的葡萄园（往往规模很小）营销为古老高卢传统的体现。
from the new world and they can say, well, look, you may have this, you may have that, but you don't have our tradition and our terroix. Right. Right. because just because something is deeply felt on a kind of spiritual dimension doesn't mean that you can't use it to flog wine, which is exactly what the French are doing, particularly in places where they don't have exclusive chateau, like in Bordeaux. So Burgundy would be the perfect example. Again, a very, very famous area of France, but because it's not connected by the sea to England, it doesn't have this kind of history, this pedigree. And so they, in Burgundy, they market their vineyards, which tend to be on a very small scale, as being embodiments of kind of ancient Gallic tradition.
这些传统基本上是1920年代的发明。这非常像我们做的关于意大利食物历史的节目。我的意思是，你发现所有这些传统完全是，你知道，20世纪完全的营销发明。它们被营销是因为游客喜欢它们。这有助于销售，你知道，所有这些来自勃艮第的葡萄酒，否则可能没有现成的市场。正如你所说，这也是在第二次世界大战后的世界中，打击新世界竞争的一种方式，因为在那里你开始在加利福尼亚、澳大利亚遇到竞争者。
These traditions are basically an invention of the 1920s. It's very like the episode we did on the history of Italian food. I mean, you discover that all these traditions are completely, you know, complete marketing inventions in the 20th century. And they're marketed because tourists love them. And it helps to sell, you know, all these wives. from Burgundy that otherwise wouldn't have perhaps a ready market. And as you say, it's also a way in the world that follows the Second World War of slapping down competition in the new world because there you were starting to get pretenders in California, in Australia,
这些传统基本上是20世纪20年代的发明。这很像我们之前做的那期关于意大利美食历史的节目。我的意思是，你会发现所有这些传统完全是，你知道的，20世纪完全出于营销目的的发明。它们之所以被推广，是因为游客喜欢它们。这有助于销售，你知道的，所有这些来自勃艮第的葡萄酒，否则它们可能没有现成的市场。正如你所说，这也是二战后世界范围内打击新世界竞争的一种方式，因为当时你在加利福尼亚、澳大利亚等地开始出现竞争者，
in New Zealand, in South Africa, all of which are places without ancient chateau, without kind of jovial peasants, steeply rooted in the soil with traditional festivities that have been invented in the 1920s. And it's a way of saying to the world, there is no way that any wine can compete with a wine that has been grown in the terroix of Burgundy or of Bojolet or of the Longadok or wherever. Well, people genuinely believe that, didn't they, for a long time, until the 1970s, the most interesting decade in history. And we come to our final moment, which is the judgment of Paris. So that's 1976. And actually members of the rest of history club will be hearing a bit more about this on a bonus episode on Wednesday with the great
在新西兰、在南非，这些地方都没有古老的城堡，没有那种深深扎根于土地、在20世纪20年代才发明出来的传统节日的快乐农民。这其实是在向世界宣告：没有任何葡萄酒能与在勃艮第、博若莱、朗格多克或其他任何地方的风土中种植出来的葡萄酒相媲美。好吧，人们长期以来确实是这样认为的，直到20世纪70年代，这是历史上最有趣的十年。我们来到了最后的时刻，也就是“巴黎审判”。那是1976年。事实上，“历史其余部分”俱乐部的成员将在周三的特别节目中听到更多关于这件事的内容，嘉宾是伟大的
wine writer Henry Jeffries who will be talking about this and indeed about wine in the new world and the history behind it and the relationship with the British Empire and so on. So that's on Wednesday. But Tom, tell us a little bit about the judgment of Paris because this is probably the most celebrated moment, one of those controversial moment, in the entire modern history of winemaking. So it's a wine tasting competition that staged in 1976 in Paris by an English wine merchant called Stephen Spurrier. And it's interesting that the English are still kind of hanging around in France as arbiters of taste, even in the 70s. And he's opened up a wine shop in Paris and a wine school. And he's very keen to market
葡萄酒作家亨利·杰弗里斯，他将谈论这个话题，以及新世界的葡萄酒、其背后的历史以及与大英帝国的关系等等。所以那是周三的内容。但是汤姆，给我们讲讲“巴黎审判”吧，因为这可能是整个现代酿酒史上最著名、也是最具争议的时刻之一。这是一场1976年在巴黎举办的葡萄酒品鉴比赛，由一位名叫斯蒂芬·斯普里尔的英国葡萄酒商发起。有趣的是，即使在70年代，英国人仍然以品味仲裁者的身份在法国徘徊。他在巴黎开了一家葡萄酒商店和一所葡萄酒学校。他非常热衷于向法国人推销
New World wines to the French who are very reluctant to buy them. And so essentially he's trying to think of some kind of whee's that would enable him to promote the New World wines in a way that the French might respond to. The problem he faces is that the French are convinced that Californian wines and American wines more generally are terrible. And in the 1970s, you can kind of see why the French would assume this, because essentially the story of Californian wine focuses pretty much everything that the French despise about America more generally. You know, there's a lot of anti-Americanism in France in this period. So Californian wine, it's all about vulgarity, the French think.
新世界的葡萄酒，而法国人非常不情愿购买。所以本质上，他想出了一些妙招，使他能够以法国人可能接受的方式推广新世界葡萄酒。他面临的问题是，法国人坚信加州葡萄酒乃至美国葡萄酒总体上都很糟糕。在20世纪70年代，你可以理解为什么法国人会这样认为，因为加州葡萄酒的故事几乎集中体现了法国人对美国总体上所鄙视的一切。你知道，那个时期的法国存在很多反美情绪。所以法国人认为，加州葡萄酒全是庸俗的代名词。
And the archetype for this vulgarity is a guy called Leland Stanford, who was a railroad entrepreneur. Yeah. It became governor of California. And, of course, he's the founder of the university that is named after him, Stanford University. And Stanford goes on holiday to Bordeaux and he tours all the great vineyards. And he thinks, I'd like a bit of this. I could have this in California. And he goes back home. Not only does he want a bit of Bordeaux, he wants to do it on a much larger scale. And so he plants these massive vineyards.
而这种庸俗的典型代表是一个名叫利兰·斯坦福的人，他是一位铁路企业家。是的，他后来成为了加州州长。当然，他还是以他名字命名的大学——斯坦福大学的创始人。斯坦福去波尔多度假，参观了所有伟大的葡萄园。他想，我也想要一点这个。我可以在加州也搞这个。于是他回到家。他不仅想要一点波尔多，他还想以更大的规模来做。于是他种植了这些巨大的葡萄园。
But the problem is he doesn't know about Téroix. He plants it on very kind of rich soil on an enormous scale. he hasn't scoped out the climate. And the problem is that the vines just don't give the grapes of the standard that he requires. So by 1890, it's his fourth vintage. And it's terrible. And he produces two million gallons of wine. And the standard is so low that all of it has to be distilled into brandy. So, you know, when the news of that reaches, Borto, everyone thinks it's hilarious and confirms them in all their darkest suspicions.
但问题是他不懂“风土”。他在非常肥沃的土壤上大规模地种植。他没有考察过气候。问题在于，葡萄藤产出的葡萄达不到他要求的标准。到了1890年，这是他的第四个年份。结果很糟糕。他生产了200万加仑的葡萄酒。由于标准太低，所有这些酒都不得不被蒸馏成白兰地。所以，当这个消息传到波尔多时，每个人都觉得这很滑稽，并证实了他们内心最阴暗的猜疑。
To be fair, we've all had American wines that taste like that. But then, so a huge problem for American winemakers is that a love for Americans think they shouldn't be making wine at all because they don't think alcohol should have any place in American culture. Right. And so this, of course, is the strain of puritanism in American culture, which French wine growers also despise. And the great manifestation of this is the prohibition of alcohol between 1920 and 1933, which completely destroys the Californian wine industry, which had just been starting to kind of get on its feet. at that point. Americans are superb at selling stuff and they have lawyers who are superb at kind of getting around legal restrictions. So there's a lot of entrepreneurial ingenuity invested into attempts to try and get round prohibition. So would-be winemakers in America can order packages of pressed grapes from the vineyards that have survived in California. And these will be sent to you and they're called wine bricks.
平心而论，我们都喝过那种味道的美国葡萄酒。但话说回来，美国酿酒商面临的一个巨大问题是，许多美国人认为他们根本不应该酿酒，因为他们认为酒精在美国文化中不应有一席之地。没错。当然，这就是美国文化中清教徒主义的倾向，法国酿酒商也对此深恶痛绝。这种倾向最伟大的体现就是1920年至1933年间的禁酒令，它彻底摧毁了当时才刚刚起步的加州葡萄酒产业。美国人非常擅长销售，而且他们有非常擅长绕过法律限制的律师。因此，人们投入了大量的创业智慧来试图绕过禁酒令。所以，美国的准酿酒商可以从加州幸存的葡萄园订购压榨好的葡萄包。这些会被寄给你，它们被称为“葡萄酒砖”。
And they will be accompanied by a yeast pill. There's a warning accompanies this yeast pill. It says, on no account, use this yeast pill, whatever you do. And I quote, if you do use it, this will turn into wine, which would be illegal. So don't do it. Yeah. I mean, to be fair, it sounds like the wine would be terrible that you're making it with a pill and a brick of grapes. Yeah, but it's alcoholic, I guess, would be the take.
它们会附带一颗酵母丸。这颗酵母丸附带一个警告。上面写着：无论如何，千万不要使用这颗酵母丸。我引用一下：“如果你使用了它，它会变成葡萄酒，这是违法的。所以不要这样做。”是的。我的意思是，平心而论，听起来用一颗药丸和一块葡萄砖酿出来的酒会很难喝。是的，但我想重点是它含有酒精。
And the other thing that people do is to register as rabbis. So to quote Kathleen Burke in her forthcoming book on the history of wine, the Jewish faith requires the religious use of wine in the home. Anybody could call himself a rabbi and get a permit to buy wine legally, merely by presenting a list of his congregation. Millions of all faiths and no faith became members of fake synagogues, some without their knowledge when the lists were copied from telephone directories. There's also quite a lot of people in this period who are registering themselves as priests
人们做的另一件事是注册为拉比。引用凯瑟琳·伯克即将出版的关于葡萄酒历史的书中的话：“犹太信仰要求在家庭中进行葡萄酒的宗教用途。任何人都可以自称拉比，只需提交一份会众名单，就能获得合法购买葡萄酒的许可。”数百万各种信仰甚至没有信仰的人成为了假犹太教堂的成员，有些人甚至是在名单从电话簿中被抄袭时在不知情的情况下加入的。这一时期还有很多人把自己注册为牧师
and so on making wine for the use. Eucharist. That's nothing that helps the French to think that California winemakers will be good. And then there's the whole kind of the sense that Americans are willing to sacrifice quality on the altar of commercialism. I mean, they are all over very sweet wines, wines flavored with chocolate, cranberry flavored wines. I mean, basically whatever the consumer wants. God. And French wine drinkers just stray their hands up and kind of say the horror, the horror. So, Stephen Spurrier, realizing the scale of the challenge. decides the stage this blind tasting of French and Californian wines,
等等，为了圣餐仪式酿酒。这无助于让法国人认为加州酿酒商会做得很好。此外，还有一种感觉，即美国人愿意为了商业利益而牺牲质量。我的意思是，他们到处都是非常甜的葡萄酒，巧克力味的葡萄酒，蔓越莓味的葡萄酒。基本上消费者想要什么就有什么。天哪。法国葡萄酒饮用者只是举起双手说：“太可怕了，太可怕了。”所以，斯蒂芬·斯普里尔意识到挑战的规模，决定举办这场法国和加州葡萄酒的盲品会，
and he brings in nine French wine experts who will do it blind. I mean, by the way, wine experts, some of these people are the arbiters of French wine. Yeah. So, I mean, there's the head of the Inological Institute of France. There is the head of the Wine Academy. There is the Inspector General of the Appellation d'Origine Controllay Board, which is basically the board that decides whether your wine. you know, gets appellation status, gets the sort of badge of quality. So these are not just like
他请来了九位法国葡萄酒专家进行盲品。顺便说一下，这些葡萄酒专家中有些人是法国葡萄酒的仲裁者。是的。所以，我的意思是，有法国酿酒研究所的负责人。有葡萄酒学院的院长。有原产地命名控制委员会的总督察，这基本上就是决定你的葡萄酒是否获得产区地位、获得质量标志的委员会。所以这些人不仅仅是
the wine critic of Le Figaro or something. These are like proper people. Yeah. So their decisions will echo and reverberate around France and perhaps beyond. So what do they, what do they decide? So they're presented with the whites first and, you know, this kind of wine equivalent of the Academy Francaise deliver their opinion. and it's a shocker. A Californian chardonnay comes in first, then a burgundy, and then two more Californian chardonnays. So sacrableu.
《费加罗报》的葡萄酒评论家之类的。这些人是真正的大人物。是的。所以他们的决定将在法国乃至更远的地方产生回响。那么，他们决定了什么？他们首先品尝的是白葡萄酒，你知道，这种相当于法国科学院的葡萄酒专家们发表了他们的意见。结果令人震惊。一款加州霞多丽排在第一，然后是勃艮第，接着又是两款加州霞多丽。真是天哪。
Then it's time for the Reds, and surely this time French wine will step up to the plate. But no. Again, the result is a bombshell. So the 1970 Chateau-Mouton-Rost-Child comes in second. And remember, it's just been promoted to the top league by this point. So it really should be, you know, at the top.
接下来是红葡萄酒，这一次法国葡萄酒肯定会挺身而出吧。但并没有。结果再次像一颗重磅炸弹。1970年的木桐酒庄葡萄酒排在第二。记住，它当时刚刚被提升到顶级行列。所以它真的应该，你知道，处于顶端。
But it isn't because the wine that is voted number one comes from a Californian vineyard that had only been planted in 1970. Yeah, Stag's Leap. And it had been planted brilliantly by a man called Warren Winniusky. So I mean, couldn't be more American. It's new and it's printed by a bloke called Warren. And Spurier had invited, actually, I think Spurier's partner, who is American, had invited the Paris correspondent of Time magazine to watch it. And he writes it up. Last week in Paris, France, at a formal wine tasting organized by Spurier, the unthinkable happened. California defeated all Gaul. And there is a tone there of, you know, maybe a Roman crowing over the Greeks. after they've been defeated by Italian wines in 50 BC or a Canaanite, perhaps celebrating the
但事实并非如此，因为被投票选为第一名的葡萄酒来自一个1970年才种植的加州葡萄园。是的，鹿跃酒庄。它是由一个名叫沃伦·维尼亚斯基的人出色地种植的。所以我的意思是，这再美国不过了。它是新的，而且是由一个叫沃伦的家伙种植的。斯普里尔邀请了——其实我想是斯普里尔的合伙人，他是美国人——邀请了《时代》周刊的巴黎记者来观看。他写道：“上周在法国巴黎，在斯普里尔组织的一次正式葡萄酒品鉴会上，不可思议的事情发生了。加州击败了整个高卢。”那里有一种语气，你知道，也许就像罗马人在公元前50年被意大利葡萄酒击败后对希腊人的嘲讽，或者迦南人，也许在庆祝
victory of the Becker Valley over a rainy in 3,000 BC. And, I mean, it's had a pretty seismic impact, I think, hasn't it, on the prestige, not just of Californian wines, but of New World wines generally. Oh, totally. And I guess Henry will be talking more about that. But I think, I mean, I think it's important to emphasize, it isn't just a story of the new world banquishing the old, because I think. think France definitely retains its prestige even today. So we've said already that there are lots
公元前3000年贝卡谷地对雷尼的胜利。我的意思是，我认为这对加州葡萄酒乃至新世界葡萄酒的声望产生了相当巨大的影响，不是吗？哦，完全是。我想亨利会谈论更多关于这一点。但我认为，强调这一点很重要，这不仅仅是一个新世界战胜旧世界的故事，因为我认为法国即使在今天也绝对保持着它的声望。所以我们已经说过，有很多
of vineyards in California with the name Chateau in the title. Well, one of those wines in the judgment of Paris was from a winery, I think founded in something like 1971 or 1972 called Claudeauvel. So given a kind of artificial, contrived French name to denote quality. Yeah. And The Americans, you know, have massively invested in Bordeaux as the British had done before them and as the Chinese are doing now. And it's kind of interesting that a setback, maybe you can kind of track the course of superpower status by the degree to which a country can invest in Bordeaux. So Britain and its great imperial age was investing in America, now China. And the notion of terroir we've said, you know, it's like a cutting from Burgundy, has a, been transplanted to the opposite ends of the world. So in New Zealand, that wine grows there
加州的葡萄园在名称中带有“城堡”一词。嗯，巴黎审判中的那些葡萄酒之一来自一家酒庄，我想是1971年或1972年左右成立的，名叫克洛杜瓦尔。所以赋予了一个人工的、刻意的法国名字来表示质量。是的。美国人，你知道，已经像英国人之前所做的那样，以及中国人现在所做的那样，大规模地投资了波尔多。有趣的是，也许你可以通过一个国家投资波尔多的程度来追踪其超级大国地位的进程。所以英国在它伟大的帝国时代投资了美国，现在是中国。我们说过，风土的概念，你知道，就像从勃艮第剪下的枝条，被移植到了世界的另一端。所以，在新西兰，那里的葡萄酒种植者
are particularly keen on the notion of terroir, and it's been mingled with, and I hope I get the pronunciation of this right. It's a Maori notion of belonging to a particular place called Turung-Uwai-Wai. I mean, that trips off the tongue. I probably haven't pronounced that right, and it means literally a place to stand, apparently. So ending on a kind of a rending note. I like to think that the history of wine isn't just about competition, but it's about partnership. Oh, isn't that kind? That's a nice note on which to end.
特别热衷于风土的概念，并且它已经与——我希望我能正确发音——一种毛利人的归属感概念融合在一起，叫做“Turung-Uwai-Wai”。我的意思是，这很拗口。我可能发音不准，显然它字面意思是“站立的地方”。所以以一种感人的方式结束。我喜欢认为葡萄酒的历史不仅仅是关于竞争，而是关于伙伴关系。哦，那多好啊？这是一个很好的结束语。
I think it's about competition, frankly, but there you go. You're probably right. But I think, I mean, I think ultimately if you're not a kind of wine chauvinist, but just someone who enjoys wine, then it doesn't really matter. You know, Carpe diem. And so I think it would be nice to end on a note of poetry. We've had quite a lot of poetry. And this is poetry that says ultimately it doesn't matter what the history of wine has been.
坦率地说，我认为这是关于竞争，但随你怎么说。你可能是对的。但我认为，我的意思是，我认为最终如果你不是那种葡萄酒沙文主义者，而只是一个享受葡萄酒的人，那么这真的不重要。你知道，“及时行乐”。所以我认为以诗歌作为结尾会很好。我们已经读了很多诗。这首诗说，归根结底，葡萄酒的历史是什么并不重要。
And it doesn't matter what will be. And this comes from a Persian like Rumi, another great devotee of wine. And this is Omar Kayam. Ah, fill the cup. What boots it to repeat? How time is slipping underneath our feet. unborn tomorrow and dead yesterday, why fret about them if today be sweet? Lovely.
未来会怎样也不重要。这来自一位像鲁米一样的波斯人，另一位伟大的葡萄酒爱好者。这就是奥马尔·海亚姆。“斟满杯子。重复这些有什么用？时光在我们脚下悄然流逝。未出生的明天和死去的昨天，如果今天甜蜜，何必为它们烦恼？”可爱。
Such an interesting story. And if you're interested in hearing more about the history of wine, we will be talking about wine in the new world and its relationship to deeper historical changes, not least the rise and fall of the British Empire. In Wednesday's bonus episode for Restis History Club members with the great wine writer and friend of the show, Henry Jeffries. And if you're not a member of the club and you'd like to hear that episode, you merely need to head to The Restishistory.com to sign up. And of course, if you're keen to
真是个有趣的故事。如果你有兴趣了解更多关于葡萄酒的历史，我们将讨论新世界的葡萄酒及其与更深层历史变革的关系，尤其是大英帝国的兴衰。在周三为“历史其余部分”俱乐部成员提供的特别节目中，嘉宾是伟大的葡萄酒作家和节目的朋友，亨利·杰弗里斯。如果你不是俱乐部的成员，想听那一集，你只需要前往 TheRestIsHistory.com 注册即可。当然，如果你热衷于
hear more about the history of wine or indeed about the subject of our next regular episode, which is about the Mona Lisa, then there will be lots more in our Super Sorroway new newsletter to which I'm very much looking forward. All right. Thank you very much, Tom. Cheers and saunate everybody. Bye-bye. Goodbye, everyone. We've got some brilliant news, a new The Rest is History book. is heading your way and it is called A History of the World in 51 heroes and villains and it's got everything that you would expect. It's got mad battles. It's got sensational sex scandals. It's got lots of Machiavellian wheeling and dealing. It's brilliant. And along the way Tom and I will be
听到更多关于葡萄酒的历史，或者关于我们下一期常规节目的主题，也就是关于蒙娜丽莎的内容，那么我们非常期待的“超级周三”新时事通讯中会有更多内容。好的。非常感谢你，汤姆。干杯，祝大家健康。再见。再见，大家。我们有一个好消息，一本新的《历史其余部分》书籍即将推出，它叫《51位英雄与恶棍眼中的世界史》，它包含了你所期待的一切。它有疯狂的战斗。它有轰动的性丑闻。它有很多马基雅维利式的权谋。它太棒了。一路上，汤姆和我将
debating some of the most important questions of history. So, for example, was Caligula an irredeemable monster or was he simply an early example of an influencer? Was Vuech the Bear? a true hero of the Second World War or was he more of a cuddly mascot and was Elizabeth the first really a virgin queen or was she just brilliant at branding? So polish up your armour, twirl your massive First World War General's moustache and prepare to take a side between heroes and villains.
辩论一些历史上最重要的问题。例如，卡里古拉是一个无可救药的怪物，还是他只是一个网红的早期例子？维泰克熊是二战中真正的英雄，还是更像一个可爱的吉祥物？伊丽莎白一世真的是童贞女王，还是她只是擅长品牌营销？所以擦亮你的盔甲，卷起你那巨大的第一次世界大战将军胡子，准备在英雄和恶棍之间选边站吧。
Yes, a history of the world in 51 heroes and villains is available to pre-order now. Don't miss out. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，《51位英雄与恶棍眼中的世界史》现在可以预订了。不要错过。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。